quelques années lors de son record il
avait duré près de cinq heures et
avaient répondu à 100 questions
exactement alors c'est un exercice qu'il
affectionne vous l'avez également évoqué
depuis 2001 il le fait chaque année à
l'exception de la durée de son mandat de
premier ministre chaque année en tant
que président il répond pendant
plusieurs heures aux questions des
journalistes
on voit antoine a sur ces images que les
journalistes sont placés quand même à
bonne distance les uns des autres
donc toutes les mesures de restriction
donc ont été prises pour cette
visioconférence
oui tout à fait dans l'endroit où je me
trouve de nombreux passages de sécurité
nous nous sommes fait tester la
température des différents journalistes
a été relevée il existe tous les 50
mètres des endroits pour pouvoir se
désinfecter les mains et comme vous
pouvez le voir sur ces images une
distanciation entre 1 m 50 et 2 mètres
entre chaque chaise pour les
journalistes qui se trouve à l'intérieur
de l'enceinte donc comme je le disais
moitié moins que l'année dernière
l'année dernière les années précédentes
ils étaient 1500 1600 et souvent avec
des pancartes ou en costume traditionnel
afin d'attirer l'attention du porte
parole du kremlin ou du président
lui-même afin que les questions soient
posées à ses journalistes cette année
c'est beaucoup plus sobre j'ai envie de
dire je n'ai pas vu de ce type de
commandes hier de deux journalistes très
très coloré contrairement à ce qu'on a
pu voir les années précédentes mais nul
doute que les quatre heures seront
largement dépassés encore cette fois
encore cette fois cette année quatre à
quatre heures de pointe presse pour
vladimir poutine encore une fois cette
année sur le format encore une fois
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire
vladimir poutine
ou est-ce qu'il se trouve précisément
parvenir poutine se trouve dans sa
résidence qui se trouve à l'ouest de
moscou dans sa résidence de novo
ogaryovo qui se trouve à une trentaine
ou une quarantaine de kilomètres du
centre de la capitale
et donc ce sera en visioconférence mais
la plupart des journalistes eux se
trouvent ici face à un écran alors qu'en
temps normal il se trouve face au bureau
et au pupitre du président de la
fédération possible et le jeu de
questions et prononce rarement ça va se
dérouler cette année
alors il ya toujours un pupitre dans la
pièce dont il y aura une personne qui
qui choisira l'interlocuteur à vladimir
poutine
mais il est également probable que
vladimir poutine d'où ils se trouvent
pour a demandé à parler à un certain
journaliste alors les gens de liste on
avait eu des mots sur le nom de leur
média soit je vous interromps antoine
parce que j'ai dit merci steam c'est ça
la regarde et vous tous ceux du call
center et à tous ceux qui sont dans les
entités de la fédération partout et
aujourd'hui nous procédons à la dernière
conférence de presse dès cette année
étant donné les conditions du coc vide
nous n'avons pas pu organiser des
conférences de presse ou les modalités
habituelles mais il ya quand même un
certain élément de la ligne directe qui
ont été conservés pour que chacun puisse
se parler en direct et on puisse entendu
entendre les opinions de diverses
personnes dans le pays les propositions
qui peuvent être faites sur les
améliorations et les choses a ajouté
qu'ils peuvent être faites pour répondre
aux questions aux défis qui se posent
aujourd'hui pour être un peu plus
efficace et je voudrais tout de suite
précisé que nous avons après les
dernières années une très bonne
expérience
nous avons beaucoup de questions des
centaines de questions qui sont posées
et je tiens à remercier temps mes
collègues de l'administration
présidentielle que au niveau du
gouvernement mais surtout toutes les
associations qui est notamment la
chambre et steve hill qui font en sorte
que les volontaires sur le terrain
puissent contribuer à l'organisation de
cela est que
les
de gens puissent poser des questions
entrez dans un contact direct et
soulever les questions qui se posent
aujourd'hui au niveau local on a souvent
pu résoudre un certain nombre de
questions qui avaient été posées
concrètement jeu j'espère bien que nous
pourrons cette année continuer à agir de
la sorte il ya les membres de
l'association du front national de
russie
je dirais que je tiens à préciser aussi
que cette rencontre n'est pas simplement
une formalité que pour moi c'est
important
il ya un très grand flux d'informations
sur ce qui se passe dans le coin de pays
qui ce qui me parvient et il n'y a rien
de plus important de plus précieux qu'il
ya un contact en direct avec les
citoyens de la fédération de russie et
il n'y a rien de plus précieux que de
savoir justement l'opinion de chacun sur
la façon dont nous vivons dans le pays
et sur ce qu'il faut faire pour
améliorer la situation et je m'arrêterai
là pour mon mot d'introduction on va
passer aux questions
je vais donc céder la parole à dmitri
peskov qui se trouve donc dans le centre
d'appels c'est lui qui va servir de
modérateur pour cette discussion
bonjour l'admirent la di muro niche un
jour maintenant nous avons beaucoup de
centres dans centres d'appels dans notre
pays on commence par vladivostok à ce
bref s'il vous plaît pour que plus de
journalistes puissent poser leurs
questions relatives aux stocks bonjour
bonsoir assez relative aux stocks la
capitale un du plus grand district
fédéral dans notre pays
cinquante journalistes sont présents ici
et chacun
à son audience ces questions à poser à
notre président je propose de commencer
et il y à déjà ceux qui veulent poser
leurs questions monsieur parce qu à vous
de choisir qui sera le premier centre et
s'il vous plaît la salle je crois que je
veux matane
oui hein vous la parole bonjour geyter
camac adage mattel le ménagères bacs au
va tout d'abord je voudrais saluer vous
monsieur poutine et tous les
téléspectateurs
et voilà je voudrais poser la question
suivante bien sûr tout le monde comme
franck c'est un été assez difficile et
cette année était plutôt mauvaise ou est
ce qu'il y avait quelque chose de bon
bon évidemment l'année comme on peut
dire que l'année a été mauvaise est ce
que le temps la météo est mauvaise après
beau temps il peut être beau ce que je
veux dire c'est que il ya des avantages
et des inconvénients comme toujours dans
la ville bien entendu cette année elle
est liée aux problèmes auxquels nous
avons tous été confrontés et qui nous
préoccupe tous et la pandémie
ceci est caractéristique pas seulement
pour nous pour là aussi mais ça concerne
l'ensemble du monde
nous savons que 70 millions de personnes
ont été concernées par cette pandémie
donc c'est un problème qui aura laissé
une trace dans la vie de tous de chacun
donc cette pandémie on a tous été
frappés c'est et des pertes d'emploi
c'est des diminution du volume des
transports c'est donc des emplois en
moins une baisse de revenus
malheureusement et tout cela on a vu que
ça a existé mais je voudrais attirer
votre attention sur un autre point c'est
première chose je vais donner quelques
chiffres c'était malgré l'ensemble de
problèmes que nous avons rencontrés sont
c'est un océan de problème et c'est pour
ça qu'on se rencontre aujourd'hui c'est
pour en parler
malgré tous ces problèmes tout cet océan
de problème il est partout il est dans
le monde entier
mais on peut dire avec certitude que
nous avons pris ce problème à bras le
corps de façon positive et mieux que
dans d'autres pays nous avons su
répondre à ces défis et nous avons le
droit d'être fiers de la stabilité de
notre économie et de la stabilité des
systèmes sociaux des systèmes de santé
qui fonctionne dans notre pays ici bon
j'ai évidemment des antisèches mais je
vais pas vous inonder de chiffres non
plus mais à l'heure actuelle on a une
baisse de la production de 3 6% sur
l'ensemble du par rapport à l'ensemble
du pib c'est à dire que c'est moi que
dans la plupart des pays européens c'est
moins que aux états unis et la baisse du
pib dans certains pays européens a même
été de 9%
donc on a ici une production un
industriel qui a baissé de 3% est
essentiellement cela est dû aux aux
évolutions du marché du pétrole
il ya eu des réductions de l'extraction
et tout cela évidemment a eu un impact
sur nos résultats
alors est-ce que ça a été meilleur est
ce que c'était pire ça dépend des
secteurs justement au niveau du
gouvernement
hier on m'a dit que on a eu une
augmentation de 1 1% cette année de haut
niveau de la transformation des produits
pétroliers ça veut dire que on a quand
même l'espoir de pouvoir continuer de
façon positive donc traditionnellement
pour ces dernières années on a de bons
résultats au niveau de l'agriculture
on est à + 8 %
on aurait peut-être même deux pour cent
d'ici la fin de l'année quand on aura
tous les chiffres
le secteur bancaire se trouve dans un
bon état
on est à 1300 milliards de milliers de
milliards de roubles cette année pour le
secteur bancaire
je tiens tout de suite je vous prie de
ne pas vous vexer mais je comprends que
tout cela ne correspond pas aux
impressions que vous pouviez avoir dans
la vie réelle mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que l'ensemble de ces chiffres ne
dit qu'on pourrait vous pourrez avoir
quand même compter sur 1 5%
d'augmentation des salaires dans l'année
alors pourquoi on a pourquoi on à ces
chiffres et d'où viennent d'où vient
cette en quoi réside cette différence
entre les problèmes kia et malgré tous
ces chiffres qui sont positifs parce que
on a aussi en même temps pour constater
une baisse de 3% de l'ensemble des
revenus de la population et dans
certains secteurs c était de 4,7 pour
cent voire 6 3%
mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il ya
un certain nombre de mesures ont été
adoptées pour aider les secteurs qui ont
le plus souffert et surtout pour le
maintien de l'emploi
c'est à dire que les emplois ont été
préservés et j'espère que nous pourrons
conserver dans l'année qui vient cette
tendance positive mais aussi c'est la
même chose au niveau du volume des
échanges commerciaux
on a une dette souveraine qui étaient
très minces qui était de 70 milliards de
dollars et qui a baissé de 10 milliards
de dollars donc nous honorons tous nous
toutes nos obligations nous réservons
augmenté on est à 554 milliards de
dollars est ici début décembre on est à
2 587 7 milliards de dollars donc on a
presque treize mille milliards de
réserves aujourd'hui ce qui signifie
qu'on voit très clairement des éléments
de développement économiques tout à fait
positives c'est à dire 70 % du budget de
l'état russe est fort mais n'ont pas pas
à partir du secteur
mais pétrolier et gazier
ça veut dire ce qu'ils continuent à nous
présenter comme un pays qui se résument
qui se résume à une station d'essence se
trompent
enfin ce que je voudrais dire aussi
c'est que cette année qui s'achève
elle est liée aussi à un certain nombre
de projets très importants pour notre
pays c'est par exemple le 75e
anniversaire de la victoire sur le
nazisme c'est malgré la pandémie nous
avons su célébrer nous avons eu un
défilé militaire sur la place rouge nous
avons donné toutes formes le format
nécessaires à l'ensemble de ces
célébrations
et tout cela ce sont des nombreuses mais
l'essentiel au delà de tout ça et
j'attire votre attention là dessus c'est
que je tiens à remercier tous les
citoyens aux dieux pays c'était de dire
que nous avons vu que cette identité
russell se maintient malgré toutes les
menaces et toutes les difficultés et
malgré tout ce que nous avons pu voir
cette année on a vu la mobilisation du
personnel médical à la mobilisation des
bénévoles dans les associations au
niveau social et tu te tout ce mouvement
d'ensemble de soutien de cohésion de
solidarité auprès de ceux qui sont dans
le besoin et cette union nationale jeudi
à tout ça c'est une manifestation
extérieure de la mentalité de la société
et je pense que tout ça c'est tout à
fait déterminant pour notre société
et ça pour cela je tiens à manifester ma
gratitude à l'ensemble de la population
russe
c'est très important je vous remercie je
tiens
il faut tenir le micro pour l avoir posé
la question et il faut respecter les
règles sanitaires et maintenant le pool
de kremlin novo ogarevo à vous la parole
et voilà qu'à à vous la parole
merci
alexei petrov la chaîne rossiya monsieur
poutine
les masques c'est le symbole de notre
époque
malheureusement et bien évidemment la
pandémie c'est l'événement plaies de
cette année je voudrais posez vous une
question sur la situation dans notre
système de santé publique
ce système réussi à remporter le défi
parce qu'il ya une chose très importante
selon vous expliquer analyse un examen
des problèmes d échec parce que il ya un
manque de médicaments mais aussi
l'étiquetage des médicaments et
il ya aussi un autre aspect le niveau le
premier niveau du santé du système de
santé public avec moi on doit appliquer
cette expérience survie en ce qui
concerne la disponibilité du système de
santé
bien sûr vu les proportions du mal aucun
système de santé dans le monde entier
ils étaient préparés simplement ça ça
n'existe pas de nous avons analysé tout
ce qui se passe dans le monde
il n'y a pas d'analogie mais il ya eu
des exemples notamment d'un autre pays
parce que tout ce qu'il faut c'est un
océan de problèmes que nous avons il
faut bien avoir des choses mais comparer
mais tout se compare par rapport à ce
qui se passe dans le monde entier sur
notre système s'est avéré plus efficace
vous dire je parlerai de médicaments où
ils sas
bien sûr ça va de soi oui nous sommes au
courant et l'analyse des questions qui
arrivent et votre question tout ça me
dit que tu tout n'a pas été réglé loin
s'en faut mais depuis le début de la
pandémie des dés les premiers indices
cac nos amis de la république populaire
de chine nous ont signalé qu'il y avait
des choses à ce niveau nous avons réagi
immédiatement et nous avons gagné
malgré plusieurs femmes nous avons gagné
du temps pour lancer des préparatifs
intenses au moment de l'arrivée en masse
chez nous nous avons gagné donc du toit
donc nous avons
tout ce qui pour prévenir nous n'avons
pas perdu le ta-100 part dans le temps
par ce qui concerne les lits d'hôpitaux
qui ont été préparés bon c'était 81,5 à
85 millions oui oui 95 il y avait que 50
% sont déjà prêts
aujourd'hui ça ça va 5 me dont il faut
compter par milliers voilà 170 5010 270
me dis moi voilà pour les lits
d'hôpitaux a très peu de temps nous
avons construit qu'à une quarantaine de
centres hospitaliers trentaine pour le
ministère de la défense et dizaine par
les régions donc le 40e centre
hospitalier qui va être tes cheveux vers
la fin de l'année
c'est cela montre bien notre
disponibilité notre
constitue la régir la main quand j'ai vu
une vidéo notaire qui nous a montré le
matériel médical qui était au moment du
début de la pandémie on n'avait pas de
spécial de masse et spécialistes très
peu 8033 sort alors comment tant pour le
personnel 1450 vie médecin et dans
l'ensemble pour le médicaux pour le
personnel de soin des millions ce 120
mille choses comme ça donc nous avons pu
très rapidement recentra un certain
nombre d'établissements d'institutions
médical et reformer requalifier le
personnel médical
il y a eu des suppléments de salaire
pour ceux qui travaillent dans les zones
rouges pour soutenir matériellement faux
sang pour les étudiants des années
terminal des échos des facultés de
médecine et là cette nuit pour chaque
collège
très rapidement nous ont lancé la
fabrication de moyens additionnels
induit de costumes masques respiratoires
et se fera tout ce qu'il faut pour des
effecteurs locales pour pour les masques
dogon lui tout le monde
nous avons multiplié leur production par
20 ce qui n'est pas ce qui rend ce qui
n'est pas comme un banal donc notre
système de gestion à s'est montrée prête
à mobiliser rapidement les ressources et
nous l'avons fait
oui certainement même aujourd'hui le nom
de médicaments nécessaires a été doublé
a été multiplié par deux dans certains
régions ils connaissent mal
quelques j'en ai noté quelques-unes le
call centre qui signale les deux modèles
damas hammam dans des hôpitaux de
stationnaire dans le réseau de
pharmacies il n'y a pas assez de
médicaments gratuits
là ce ne sont plus les mêmes problèmes
que nous avons connus ou au début ce
sont des problèmes de logistique et
d'achats en temps utile de livraison en
fait l'industrie a choisi rapidement au
début de la pandémie ne savions pas à
quoi nous avions peur comme en haut des
pistes comme en atteste
comment on soigne on savait pas s'il
vous pouvez trouver un antidote sous
forme avec ça donc nous avons avancé au
tour de matt pour le testing nous sommes
parmi les trois leaders mondiaux en
matière de tests est selon l' oms
un des moyens pour surmonter ces
difficultés notamment il faut tester le
testing de masse pour les médicaments
nous les fabriquons en quantité
nécessaire et pour la vaccination
la russie est le premier pays du monde à
avoir inventé france est dir est a
commencé à produire le vaccin
le centre scientifique de gamme à gamal
et le centre de novossibirsk eux qui
nous avons le vaccin la chique et de
bonne qualité qui n'ont line reculés
dont l'innocuité et l'efficacité sont
prouvés
et donc il n'a pas eu de cas sérieux
notamment de d'effets collatéraux
nos collègues mais à l'étranger ont
cessé de nous tourner le dos qui sont
prêtes à collaborer avec nous là au camp
qu il ya quelque chose qui ne marche pas
par exemple cette compagnie astrazeneca
le suédoise qui est prête à collaborer
avec nous nous sommes en train de signer
un accord dont je suis content que des
spécialistes à ce niveau-là ce niveau de
recherche c'est une grande société qui
est très crédible de qui conjuguent
leurs efforts avec des partenaires je
suis sûr que le résultat sera beau temps
pour nos citoyens que pour le monde
entier
alors tout ce que je viens de dire oui
bien sûr les problèmes ne manquent pas
mais dans l'ensemble le système de santé
a réagi d'une manière adéquate au défi
et en ce qui concerne le maillon
initialement l'échelon premier donc nous
avons dû concentrer nos ressources sur
cette chose pour lutte pour combattre
l'infection koroma virale pour aider les
médecins les volontaires des étudiants
des facultés de médecine pour lancer la
la production donc nous avons en quelque
sorte notamment pour le maillot premier
de la première échelons de la santé donc
nous n'avons pas oublié que au lieu de
commencer le 1er juillet nous allons
commencer dès le 1er janvier et toutes
les ressources qui ont été prévus pour
ce programme
le la santé publique qui seront utilisés
dans les périodes dans les délais prévus
il s'agit de ce soit milliards de
roubles du budget fédéral 50 milliards
des budgets régionaux
c'est dans les trois années à venir 300
milliards qui seront des bourses qui
seront dénoncés qui seront utilisés
utilisé dans certains domaines pour le
perfectionnement du système que nous
avons entamé par exemple l'achat de
moyen de transport il faut dès
maintenant je vois deux jours pour
répondre aux questions qui arrive c'est
il partie du programme de développement
du système de santé de base en fait
l'essentiel dans ce système de soin
médicaux de premiers soins médicaux
c'est d'assurer l'accessibilité à 100%
pour les citoyens l'accessibilité des
services de sauter donc il ya des choses
qui demandent une solution rapide
c'est là ce sera notre priorité bien sûr
la formation du personnel la base
matérielle à autre chose je m'attends à
ce qu'une partie de votre question qui
concerne m
l'art sur au problème un nom qui restent
non résolus
la lutte contre la pandémie bien sûr
nous sommes en train d'analyser
bien sûr je tiens à vous dire que
aujourd'hui ce que nous sommes en train
de faire c'est très important parce que
nous avons un flux d'informations
provenant de partout et nous savons
comment les choses se font en russie et
comme ça nous pouvons réagir et corriger
notre intervention donc la conclusion la
plus simple qui semble aller de soi bien
sûr nous devons avancer dans le sens aux
sports perfectionnement du service
sanitaire et épidémiologique qui a
besoin besoin de vraies réformes et pour
savoir combien nous faut-il de l'iss de
pitau spécialisés le nombre de
spécialistes voilà ce programme en fait
qui était d'abord et et que nous sommes
à mettre en pratique fait poser votre
question
monsieur poutine je m'appelle
internationale comme tu représentes
l'agent sur europe nous a touchés mais
elle avait continué j'ai une question à
cet égard une question générale sur les
élections la campagne électorale qui
aura lieu en 2021 selon vous en quoi
cette campagne serait-elle différente si
on la compare avec les une campagne
précédente et
la deuxième partie de ma question à
l'opposition qui existe dans le cadre de
notre système peut-être le temps est
venu de donner l'opportunité aux
nouveaux partis qui ont déjà participé
aux élections municipales
il ne sert d'un résultat est la dernière
partie de ma question portait sur
l'ingérence extérieure à comment vous
allez faire face à cette ingérence
en ce qui concerne les élections
parlementaires 2021 bien sûr il y aura
des différences qui tient tout d'abord
au fait que nous avons adopté des
amendements constitutionnels
ce qui veut dire que le parlement a eu
plus de pouvoirs pour un certain nombre
de 2 à man y compris la formation la
constitution du gouvernement de la
fédération de russie et je voudrais bien
le répéter la douma d'état est en train
de décider in fine sur le président du
gouvernement sur les ministres les
vice-premiers ministres le président il
n'a que six gains les décisions les
nominations adoptée par le parlement et
nous avons bien compris cela modifie
essentiellement la portance du corps
dépit telles responsabilités dans le
pays notamment responsabilité pour le
fonctionnement du gouvernement
donc ce lien entre le parlement le
gouvernement c'est quelque chose de très
important
premièrement deuxièmement alors ce qui
concerne les nouveaux partis les
les poids lourds dont politique ne
devrait-il pas ce genre placé pas les
nouveaux partis ni les poids lourds qui
le décide
ceci sur les citoyens c'est à eux de
décider aux électeurs ce sont eux qui
décident qui iront ils soutenir lors des
élections mais c'est notre système qui
est en train se développer qui est
évolutif qui qu'il est arrivé plus de
forces politiques pour se joindre
campagne électorale oui sûrement je
pense que cette année c'est pas mon
opinion
l'année prochaine il y aura plus de 16
parties qui repart aux campagnes
électorales sans recueillir wc nature
parce que conformément à la loi que ces
partis sont représentés dans certaines
entités fédérées et donc ils ont acquis
le droit de s'essayer au niveau national
fédéral je leur souhaite dire le succès
mais je tiens à dire encore une fois
sauce et finalement c'est le lecteur qui
décide et je l'aurai bien noté que les
partis politiques traditionnels
vous connaissez tous qui se représente à
la douma qui était présentée depuis des
années il y a parfois des poids de vie
différent qui sautent à la pause et même
à contre diamétralement opposées manière
des discussions sur un certain nombre de
problèmes que le pays et qui se posent
drones comme l'écrit thème avec cela
chacun de ces partis des positions
composition patriotiques ou notamment au
regard des tas de ceux qui se posent
devant le but les approches les outils
peuvent être différents mais l'objectif
politique pour les partis traditionnels
au mam c'est la prospérité l2 le
développement du pays
moscou est allé à novossibirsk votre
question
[Musique]
robin je vous avais déjà dit que nouveau
subissent c'est le centre la ville ou en
déversant a été mise au point et en tant
que modérateur appuis je choisis à qui
donner la parole j'ai vu je vois que
vous voulez poser une question sur le
vaccin oui le mineur est belge est une
questions est ce que vous êtes déjà
vaccinées contre le coran d'un virus et
quelle est votre attitude à la
vaccination générale de la population
aussi pour le moment le nombre de doses
n'est pas suffisant il vend le craj
d'altaï la situation sanitaire est assez
complexe et j'ai une autre question dans
ces situations est ce qu'il y aura
suffisamment de doses de vaccin pour la
russie la russie commence à fournir les
vaccins à l'étranger
regardez en ce qui concerne
c'est à dire que j'appelle chacun à être
attentifs aux recommandations de
spécialistes
je vois que vous avez mis tout de suite
votre masse c'est très bien et vous avez
vos gants c'est à dire que les
spécialistes nous disent que les vaccins
qui sont en circulation
la population sont destinés à une
certaine catégorie d'âge et pour
l'instant les gens comme moi ne sont pas
encore concernés par cette catégorie
jeune mais je respecte la loi je suis
les recommandations de nos spécialistes
est pour l'instant moi je me suis fais
pas je me suis pas fait vacciner mais je
le ferai dès que ce sera possible ça
c'est la première chose deuxième point
ce que j'entends de ce que disent les
spécialistes c'est important de bien
comprendre la différence entre les
différents vaccins un vaccin contre la
grippe c'est une chose un vaccin contre
le corps n'avait ces deux jours certains
disent qu'il faut respecter un certain
laps de temps c'est à dire de deux
semaines d'autres disent que ces quatre
semaines pour le
pour le cor navires us ça c'est le
deuxième point troisième point
concernant la nécessité d'une
vaccination de masse je pense qu'il faut
le faire c'est pas seulement les
spécialistes en virologie
ici en russie qui le disent mais les
immenses quasiment ce que dit tout le
monde dont dans les autres pays c'est
que un des moyens de surmonter la
pandémie c'est la vaccination de masse
parce que c'est elle qui doit créer une
immunité au niveau national et encore
une fois nos vaccins sont efficaces et
ils sont sans danger
donc ya pas de raison de ne pas le faire
ensuite ce qu'il faut voir c'est que il
ya l'aide aux autres pays avant tout et
ça je l' ai toujours dit et je le répète
encore une fois parce que je veux être
entendu de chacun ici notre objectif
c'est de mener la vaccination ici en
russie il ya plusieurs aspects de la
question il ya les composants de ce
vaccin qui ils sont bons aujourd'hui ce
qui nous manque pour l'instant c'est un
certain nombre d'appareils d'équipements
pour procéder est cette vaccination
ça c'est ce que nous devons faire pour
lutter contre l'infection à coronavirus
mais pour moi cela ça veut dire qu'il
faut que les entreprises concernées
produisent fabrique l'équipement
nécessaire donc ça ça va se faire ça va
se faire en croissant et tous les
programmes vont être exécutés et
dès le début de l'année nous aurons déjà
plusieurs millions de doses qui seront
disponibles en ce qui concerne la
coopération avec les autres pays en
dehors du fait qu'il nous faut un
certain temps pour que technologiquement
nous soyons en mesure de produire et de
distribuer ces vaccins rien ne nous
empêche de produire les composants des
vaccins là il faudra un investissement
qui fort qui devrait être fait pour
augmenter la production donc ici c'est
la question et cela ne nous empêche pas
de en travaillant avec les autres de
procéder à la vaccination au niveau
national au contraire je pense que nous
sommes en mesure d'améliorer la qualité
de cette de ce vaccin mais c'est poutine
se permettait je voudrais continuer avec
cette tradition
placé par un jeu monsieur pasqua on
voudrait vous gêne tout petit cadeau
pour votre micro pour protéger votre
micro pour rester là je trouve ça très
pédant de votre part il ya beaucoup de
questions dans notre centre d'appels ya
la pandémie au travail des médecins et
alexina qui se leva bénévoles elle a
examiné toutes ces questions elle a
travaillé en tant que médecin cette
année avec tina quelles sont les plantes
bonjour analysant les plantes nous avons
vu qu'il ya beaucoup de problèmes assez
graves auxquels nos concitoyens font
face il ya des problèmes concernant les
tests de dépistage l'absence de
médicaments nécessaires y compris dans
les hôpitaux est également j'ai examiné
les questions posées par les médecins
qui travaillent dans les ongles rouge
par exemple les médecins de la ville de
collo la région de mourmansk n'ont pas
reçu aucun remboursement pour le travail
avec les patients infectés par le
courant des virus dans une autre dans
certaines autres villes
il n'y a pas de remboursement non plus
il ya beaucoup de questions posées par
ceux qui travaillent dans les zones de
risque par exemple gens qui travaillent
dans la capitale
les techniciens ils travaillent dans les
zones de risque
elles sont eux les ont au bout je ne
peuvent pas fonctionner
les gens travaillent à l'avant garde de
la lutte contre la pandémie
mais il voit que ces situations c'est en
justice
monsieur poutine on a beaucoup de
demandes de questions on est plus prêt à
vous transférez c'est demande ces
questions pour les traiter une soupe ou
thiney ce qu'on peut régler ce problème
je vous remercie à lift il n'a donc je
crois que c'est hier qu'on sait en cet
entretien donc j'ai moi aussi donc des
questions qui viennent du centre
d'appels donc rien sans par exemple nous
vivons dans une petite ville les
médicaments ne nous parviennent pas
[Musique]
pourquoi les malades duclona virus
doivent se soigner à leurs propres frais
même avec le des noces tic que confirmer
nous sommes obligés de payer nous mêmes
où est l'argent
donc moi aussi ça m'a ça m'intrigue
d'autres région de riazan cet argent
donc aller stinat je m'adresse à vous et
à tous ceux qui vous ont transmis toutes
ces demandes de choses à dire ceux qui
suivent
effectivement nous avons affecté 10
milliards de roubles aux régions pour
agir de façon rapide aux questions
encore non résolus ce sont des questions
de protection de personnel par exemple 2
préparation pour les établissements
médicaux locaux et plus de 4 milliards
on était cinq milliards ont été
attribués pour financer les médicaments
pour les gens qui se soigne à domicile
je sais que pour la région de riazan
tous ceux qui étaient affectés par le
budget fédéral à la région a été versée
pourquoi les médicaments ne sont pas
disponibles ça je ne sais pas je ne
comprends pas donc les modalités
d'obtention de médicaments sont claires
il faut qu'il s'adressait à et qui n'est
que la clique confiant le diagnostic
qu'elles attribuent les médicaments est
nécessaire que toutes les demandes que
vous avez reçue par exemple toutes ces
demandes elles doivent être systématisé
parce que je suppose que dans les autres
régions où il ya des mêmes preuves et
nous allons réagir de façon concrète
donc nous avons encore attribués affecté
10 milliards aux régions pour accélérer
le processus d'identification des
malades et donc tout cet argent qui
était affecté a été versée aux régions
ça c'est clair certains gouverneurs je
suis en contact permanent avec eux et
notamment parmi les régions citées
aujourd'hui le dise que tout va bien
donc je comprends qu'il ya des cas
particuliers
je regrette que ce soit le cas mais vu
le nombre de demandes ya je pense que
c'est pas une question isolés que c'est
une question massives dont que nous
allons je vais y travailler de
concrètement très prochainement merci
maintenant on aurait bien dans le centre
de commerce international commence par
ce secteur là donnez-moi le micro s'il
vous plaît présentez-vous toujours un
mais ce putin mitis vestiaires la chaîne
ren tv
merci pour le bac sans merci où cefic on
parle beaucoup de la pandémie on oublie
que le losc la source
ces menaces les etats unis accusent la
chine la chine accuse de la vitese unis
et la russie
qu'est ce que c'est à cet égard a
peut-être vous avez demandé les services
et pour ça l'origine oui effectivement
beaucoup de bruits qui circulent je veux
pas dire devant tout le pays et le monde
entier toute chose la suite d'autant
plus qu'il ya pas de confirmation
concrètes concernant les accusations
dans un sens ou dans l'autre
ce que je veux dire ce qu'il fait ici
faut partir d'autres choses il faut unir
nos efforts pour lutter contre ce
problème qui est générale ça c'est
l'orientation correcte de la coopération
deuxièmement quand certains de nos
partenaires occidentaux ainsi sur le
fait qu' ils s'en tiennent à des
principes humanitaires dans leur
politique interne l intérieur la
politique et l'histoire
on voit qu'il faut aider ceux qui sont
dans des situations particulièrement
difficiles donc lever certaines
restrictions des restrictions sur le
plan commercial à les cards à l'égard
des pays qui qui peuvent jouer un rôle
important dans la lutte contre cette
pandémie
par exemple levé les sanctions sur les
livraisons de médicaments de matériel
médical sur les mouvements des personnes
des spécialistes notamment et je dois
noter encore une fois que la coopération
avec beaucoup de pays fonctionne très
très bien notamment avec la chine au
niveau des spécialistes au niveau des
responsables régionaux et au niveau
fédéral en ce qui concerne les services
secrets bien sûr un certain nombre de
missions se sont confiés bien évidemment
c'est pas le lieu ici de traiter de ces
questions la perle intervenants
précédents
s'interrogeait sur une intervention dans
nos élections
j'ai pas répondu je vous demande pardon
c'est pas que je veux pas en parler
c'est que je dirais qu'il y avait des
questions plus clio ritter ici c'est une
question évidemment qui est toujours
d'actualité oui évidemment il y aura
toujours des tentatives d'ingérences pas
seulement dans nos élections mais
partout est simple c'est un problème
mondial est qu'on voit partout dans tous
les pays en revanche ça on en bits monde
en est bien conscient se préparent à
cette menace
on pourra réagir de façon efficace
seulement si la majorité de nos citoyens
comprennent un que c'est une indigence
et deux que nous devons y réagir et que
c'est inadmissible que nous devons nous
mêmes décider de notre avenir
ça c'est important parce que c'est
l'état d'esprit de notre population de
notre produit
tu me vois effectivement que les médias
internet sur tout cet espace doit savoir
préserver cette
souveraineté je dirais mais ça veut pas
dire que nous sommes fermés à une
coopération concerne nous sommes tout à
fait ouverts et il n'y a peut-être pas
autant d'ouverture et de volonté de
coopération de la part des autres pays
que nous les etats unis par exemple posé
un certain nombre d'interdits autour
d'eux il n'y avait pas d'observateurs
étrangers par rapport par exemple aux
élections aux états unis alors que au
contraire nous sommes tout à fait
ouverts qui est des observateurs qui
viennent voir qui il ya des associations
il ya la chambre civile j'ai beaucoup
l'autorisation de d'être présent tant
qu'observateur ici lors des élections il
ya les représentants des partis
politiques eux mêmes via les
représentants de la presse et et cette
orientation de notre travail de notre
activité va se poursuivre pour que nous
puissions parvenir à l'essentiel et
l'essentiel c'est que nos les citoyens
de notre pays soit convaincue que les
élections se déroulent de façon ouverte
transparente et que les résultats
méritent le respect on reste ici dans le
centre de commerce international
alexandre gamme of a volé parole de
poutine tout d'abord je voudrais vous
remercier de cette réunion parce que
vous avez réuni les journalistes ce
temps là et vous savez bien que le conte
à virus a affecté de manière
considérable la vie des gens et les gens
dans la région disent que la vie d'une
très compliqué elle n'a jamais été aussi
compliqué parce que le niveau de
pauvreté est considérable et il ya
croissance de ce niveau et une baisse de
la sto à niveau de revenu et il ya une
augmentation du taux de mortalité les
prix augmentent aussi et depuis août ou
septembre on voit cette croissance
pourquoi on commence de d'examiner ces
problèmes en décembre uniquement quand
le président a parlé de ses problèmes
ce qui est un programme pour traiter ces
problèmes programme présidentiel ou
peut-être programme du gouvernement qui
pourrait aider la russie dans les
semaines à venir je représente le site
la radio et le journal komsomolskaïa
pravda
donc la situation la situation est
complexe il est hideux le début et en
disant que la pandémie impliqué la
fermeture d'un certain nombre
d'entreprises
la montée du chômage la baisse des
revenus de la population des revenus
rennes c'était pas des modèles rcd chose
que nous comprenons que vous avez de
dire ça n'a jamais été aussi durs
c'était comme un an de l'an 2000 au
dessus de la pauvreté 20 1% de la
population vivaient au dessous du seuil
de pauvreté tiers des habitants du pij
mois inférieur au revenu mini mini mama
en 2017
nous avons pu atteindre la coque de 12,3
pour cent pour ceux qui vivent au
sous-sol de la pauvreté au
malheureusement maintenant que de ces
problèmes
cette cote s'est relevé jusqu'à 13
soc 20 millions de personnes c'est c'est
beaucoup c'est toujours beaucoup oui
bien sûr nous avons un plan nous aurons
un plan d'action pour ceux qui qui qui
concerne ces personnes qui vivent dans
la pauvreté j'en parlerai plus haute
était premièrement vers 2030 qu'on
abandonne le 13 pour cent jusqu'à 5 à
6,5 pour cent des habitants vivent au
dessous du seuil de pauvreté bien sûr
ces mauvaises déjà si possible pour ça
c'est toujours mauvais mais ça c'est
chose de réaliste l'objectif est
ambitieux mais il est réaliste
maintenant en ce qui concerne les prix
oui bien sûr il y a des raisons le
procès demande d'augmentation des prix
d'argent qui sont objectives qui vit aux
opiacés coco pose à tous les coups des
différences de groupes de change il y a
ça fait pire des changes que nous sommes
sommes nous sommes obligés d'acheter à
l'étranger parce que le rouble qui est
en baisse maintenant là où cela n'est
pas lié ce n'en est pas et du suspense
objectif ne peut pas ne pas susciter une
réaction de notre part
et voilà ce qui m'a
ce qui comme en troubles et en personne
parce que mama dans mozart nous avons
une rigueur au cours des six dernières à
nous avait eu des récoltes des récoltes
record plus de 130 à 1 million de tonnes
oui bien sur le coup deux le prix du
pain
le prix de deux pattes pareil pourquoi
la montée des prix pour ceux connus
sucre paris
il faut que ma vie c'est serais d'avis a
notamment pour le prendre pour le sucre
soutenir plutôt le sucre à des travaux
le nôtre mais pas pour créer de la
rareté sur le marché à terme pour la
situer pour la consommation interne
c'est suffisant c'est un petit épisode
pourquoi c'est suffisant si dire 75% de
croissance de prix de monter ce prix est
pour l'huile
le tournesol qui qui qui monte
bon on manque de gras quoi il ya bien
sûr les eu des ventes à l'étranger et
déjà les prix internes se rapproche des
prix externe ce qui est inadmissible
voici pourquoi nous avons tenu un
langage assez dur le gouvernement a régi
il faut simplement éviter de de faire un
de faire un excès de zèle pour que les
prix soient comme ceux du marché mais
tout simplement il faudra corriger les
droits de douane et ça suffit tous ces
outils ce bien connu il en aurait dû
réagir plus rapidement mais je pense que
ça c'est ce qui se fera en vient de
signer je crois des accords entre les
producteurs et les réseaux de
distribution donc il y à des basses de
deux volumes et les distributeurs venant
au les détaillants aussi de vrais défis
chez certains commentaires il faut
regarder plus attentivement les prix et
nous continuerons à le faire j'espère
que cette réaction sera ne tardera pas
ou des journées des semaines qui
viennent
mais dans ce qui concerne ce qui me
groupe e ce qu'il faut faire pour aider
les populations en ces périodes
difficiles
tout d'abord avec le soudan pourquoi
sort de qui passe de 4 à 6,3 pour cent
nous avons augmenté sensiblement les
allocations chômage tout le monde sait
mais qui est plus important que le plus
dur c'est dans les familles nombreuses
là nous avons établi tout un programme
de soutien de 0 à 1 an et demi deux
un an et demi à 3 e et de 3 à 7 ans donc
pour la première tranche d'âge il y à
une allocation
[Musique]
aussi chaque membre de famille a des
revenus mois de 2 minimum de survie puis
hier 1,1 à 25% puis quand il y a moins
de deux par personne
ces familles ont droit à une allocation
pour chaque enfant ans au minimum à un
revenu minimal parce qu'au fond de aa3 à
a1 de 18 mois à 3 heures cinq ans et moi
les revenus sont inférieurs pour le
minimum vital d'en séparer ya à partir
du capital maternelle et pour les
enfants âgés de 3 à 7 ans donc la règle
est la suivante si on n'arrive pas à
minimum vital donc là 0,5 au revenu
minimum par en forme et nous avons
décidé en analysant la situation pour
voir comment ça se répercute elle est
revenue famille le site toutes ces
familles n'arrivent pas à à virgule rni
minimaux par personne à partir du 1er
janvier dans deux semaines dans 15 jours
nous allons payer donc à au minimum
vital parc chaque pour par chaque enfant
ce sont des mesures
rapide urgente donc il s'agit pas de
versement unique à tous les enfants âgés
de moins de 16 ans j'en parle même pas
puis il faut il faut aussi soutenir le
marché du travail j'en parlerai à part
mars est il des questions clés notamment
donc je me permets de 10 consacrer plus
de temps à cette question qui est
crucial main les anciens c'est que il
nous faut développer l'économie faire
tourner l'économie réaliser des projets
nationaux des objectifs de développement
national créé de nouveaux emplois à
terre de notre niveau nous donc
l'intelligence artificiers de la
numérisation tous ceux des secteurs
créent des secteurs plus moderne et qui
nous permettraient de train d'avoir un
travail plus en vue plus intéressant et
d'avoir eu revenus aussi plus
intéressant
voilà c'est à cela que vise tout un
ensemble de mesures que nous avons privé
dans le cadre de nos projets nationaux
n'oublie pas les régions mais bonjour
chers collègues ses faits d'armes où
nous sommes dans le centre avec le
journaliste d un tous les coins de notre
région il ya un mois 2 journalistique
que nous avons accrédité parce que une
collègue à vient de donner la vie à son
fils c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui elle est
absente
je pense que c'est une bonne raison et
que vous allez comprendre
monsieur poutine mais tous les autres
sont présents et veulent poser leurs
questions monsieur peskov
comment va-t-on agir montrez-nous la
salle s'il vous plaît
je vois les déchets la question sur les
déchets ici enlever le masque slowplay
posez votre question bonjour monsieur
poutine
je représente magnitogorsk la ville de
magnitogorsk
j'ai une question sur la réforme des
déchets on sait bien qu'elle a été
lancée en janvier
mais dans notre ville déjà en 2015 on a
signé un accord sur le projet et mai
puis cela a été bloquée pourquoi ces
traits forme cette réforme globale pour
l'ensemble de notre pays
ne bougez pas qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
je ne pense pas que cela freine
cette réforme aux îles iaas éducation
qui concerne la produire le processus de
processus de production l'imam à la
réforme à l avance donc il ya plusieurs
tâches à résoudre tout d'abord il faut
créer un secteur donc un cycle fermé de
production quand il y a donc il ya zéro
déchet donc au lieu de
de la mettre à la décharge mais sont
réutilisés récupérer il faudra faire le
tri aussi normalement on sait que vers
l'année 2030 tout cela cela répartis sur
les différents segments de déchets
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient traités
aujourd'hui l'une des tâches qui se
posent devant l'air organisateurs c'est
que c'est plus grandes responsabilités
le producteur est de ceux qui fabrique
des emballages pour que
nagios coup pour que pour que ce sont
pas les citoyens que supportent mais
plutôt les fabricants de ces produits
d'emballage c'est une pratique qui
existe pratiquement dans le monde entier
et nous allons nous en tenir aussi par
exemple dans l'industrie automobile
il y à ce qu'on appelle des frais
d'utilisation de récupération cela le
réutilisation sa sa fonction dans le
monde entier donc nous allons perse
percevoir ces frais aussi non c'est
quelque chose qui intéresse le
gouvernement et les régions donc nous y
avons consacré des ressources assez et
l'importante aucune autre ces ressources
ne pourront pas servir d'autrefois
d'autrefois
et puisque vous ne demandiez de gars que
j'ai une des questions que j'ai noté
sait lire les villes de marque d accord
ce que notamment les rejets dans
l'atmosphère
un des citoyens dit ce qui se meut dans
la pollution atmosphérique là c'était
assez inattendu parce que je sais que
[Musique]
que ces familles dans la grande usine à
beaucoup à ces travaux coupé v6 dans la
réduction de déchets dans les rues de
chez atmosphériques et d'après mes
informations il ya eu de baisse comme un
de pollution atmosphérique
olga vous même comment vous l'appréciez
vous même avec les déchets atmosphérique
à dans la ville de mariée degorce qu un
peu patriote je travaillais dans un
journal d'un autre un usine et je crois
que si si une usine existe déjà mais on
ne peut pas à le faire fermer tout d'un
coup parce que il y a plusieurs unités
je comprends que 1
beaucoup de d'habitants centre ville ils
ne vont pas aimer ce que je dis mais
parfois il y a juste
il ya juste la situation où l'eau est
trop froide et l'air n'est pas
transparent et les gens pensent que
c'est le smag mais il yad'autres
d'autres usines dans la ville
il ya parfois de d'heure qui ne sont pas
très très bon mais c'est parce j'ai pas
de réseau chaussures c'est un citoyen
qui se blesse à moi mais on peut lire ça
dans les réseaux sociaux sur les réseaux
sociaux oui ça ce problème existe mais
on s'occupe de ce bruit c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'aurais posé cette
question c'est que le combinat de
magnitogorsk maglica qui a investi
beaucoup de fonds plus que dans d'autres
entreprises métallurgiques notamment
réduire la pollution bon l'amérique en
tonnes
il ya eu une décroissance mais là c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut encore maman
qui font ce qu'il faut surveiller parce
que si on parle d'écologie
nous voulons créer un système de
capteurs dans l'ensemble du pays sur
tout le territoire du pays là où la
pollution est surtout plus grave et dans
les centres métallurgie cela ça consomme
ce secteur en priorité aussi et aux
frais du lui fabrique et je pense que
votre candidat fera part et on verra
pour suivre ce problème plus
attentivement et d'une manière plus
objective merci beaucoup pour la
question précédente
je me permettrai zoom notamment pour le
salaire des professeurs d instituteur du
village avec une charge de 18 heures
les buteurs se sergei stilmachenko qui
m'écrit ce salaire est égal à celui
d'une femme de ménage dans le même
établissement scolaire
vous savez la question est aiguë et donc
avec un jeu j'estime nécessaire j'ai pu
noter que je vous je vous dire ce qui
est arrivé puis je vous dire ce qu'il
faudra faire
pourquoi nous avons pris la décision que
que le revenu minimum à ne pourrait pas
être inférieurs au minimum vital et nous
avons donc déplacé cette échelle de
comparaison ce qui a fait que c'est ça
qui est arrivé
le salaire minimum ne peut pas être
inférieure mémo vital donc la femme de
ménage elle peut pas donc solaire a été
relevé
on aurait dû en même temps relevé ou si
le niveau de salaire pour les autres
catégories c'est ce qui n'a pas été fait
pour des raisons de restrictions
budgétaires
c'est ce que l'état fera un jour tôt ou
tard donges attirerait l'attention du
gouvernement fait que ces situations ne
peut pas être considéré comme normal on
revient ici dans le centre de commerce
international
nous avons déjà donné la parole
là au journaliste est très connue
maintenant je tiens à donner la parole à
notre jeune journaliste sergueï genou
rove jours mais ce putin
je me plais sergueï charov j'aurai
besoin de la chaîne internationale rtb
j'ai une question sur navalni mais je ne
veux pas posé cette question notre
chaîne c'est une chaîne internationale
et je tiens à poser la question suivante
pourquoi les cyber pirates russes n'ont
pas réussi à aider train pas être relu
peut-être ils sont déjà tous partis aux
états unis et 30
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire maintenant
est ce que vous pouvez l invité s'il
demande d'asile politique comme snowdon
par exemple c'est la question de notre
chaîne et voilà ma question personnelle
commet un russe un citoyen russe peut
parler de notre vie sans utiliser les
mots sur alors votre première question
je pense qu'il faut voir revoir ce film
classique du cinéma soviétique nous on
voyait que
mme hanoune utilise des mots des mots
d'argot et la langue russe est
suffisamment riche sur ce plan pour
exprimer si on a par exemple un
radiateur qui ne tombe sur les pieds
donc voilà je vous remercie déjà déjà de
ne pas avoir utilisé
largo ici contrairement à ce que vous
faites d'habitude deux sur scène et donc
merci beaucoup pour cette forme de
conversation aujourd'hui mais donc
pourquoi les hackers les pirates
informatiques russes n'ont pas aidé
train pas ce n'est pas une question
classique c'est une provocation
[Musique]
donc nous sommes pas nous sommes
intervenus dans l'élection de cette
grande puissance ça c'est clair ce sont
des inventions
ce sont des motifs qui ne savent quelque
chose c'est à pourrir les relations
entre nos deux pays et qui cherche à
éviter de reconnaître la légitimité du
président en exercice
aux etats unis donc ça se il ya des
questions qui sont propres à la
politique intérieure américaine
donc certains se sont retrouvés piégés
par les considérations politiques
intérieures aux états unis mais c'est de
chausser leur choix ils font ce qu'ils
veulent
nous partons du fait qu' il ya un
président qui a été élu et que ce
président comprendre à ce qui se passe
sur le plan intérieur comme sur le plan
extérieur c'est un homme politique
expérimenté que tous les problèmes
peut-être pas tous mais j'espère que la
nouvelle génération permettra de re 12
résoudre ces problèmes je pense que
donald trump n'a pas de nécessité de
trouver de trouver un emploi ensuite il
a un très grand soutien au centre de
deux des états unis il n'a pas
l'intention de quitter l'activité
politique si je comprends bien revient à
novo ogarevo le pool de kremlin nouveaux
accords vous s'il vous plaît tu vois
life à vous la parole
bonjour monsieur poutine
[Musique]
il y à quelques temps plusieurs enquêtes
très intéressantes ont été publiés par
exemple une cape sur votre fille son
ancien mari et messieurs chamallows va
être d'autres gens proches de vous et
cette semaine une enquête sur alexis
navalni a été oublié pourquoi l' enquête
n'a été lancé sur son foisonnement je
comprends à propos des bruits qui
circulent dans la presse
ils ont toujours existé ils vont
continuer à exister
cette lutte sur le plan médiatique qui
existe a toujours existé
souvenez vous par exemple les les
événements difficiles dans le caucase la
lutte contre le tourisme
on m'a présenté moi votre humble
serviteur sous toutes les figures
possibles
on m'a on a caricaturé avec des
incisives pointu mais je fais ce que je
considère comme nécessaire pour notre
pic
non pas pour avoir une bonne mine et
être bien vu des autres mais ce qui est
nécessaire
deuxième point en ce qui concerne mes
proches j'ai pas le temps de lire tout
ce qui est publié sous vaguement informé
j'ai une compilation mais je voudrais
attirer votre attention sur un point le
gendre du président jean le président
alors donc je posséde louis ancien
gendre oui
[Musique]
mais je sais que on continue à insister
sur ce point mais enfin bon c'est du
passé
donc le président poutine a interdit
certains d'avoir des actifs à l'étranger
non j'ai tout donné j'ai au contraire
les fonctionnaires de l'état où ils
n'ont pas le droit de voir des comptes à
l'étranger ça c'est autre chose
mais la campagne dont il est question
non il n'ya pas de patin ya pas d'argent
de l'état ici bon dans cette entreprise
à publier justement ces informations sur
cette affaire
on sait que des programmes management
pour les hauts responsables dont ya des
règles qui ont été établies il ya
d'autres règles qui sont différentes
pour d'autres responsables mais
l'essentiel
justement question sur les pirates
informatiques ont dit que des anonymes
donc des objectifs que nous ne
connaissons pas et
qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire ici on a dit
que c'était la même chose contre 2016
quant aux criminels nazis ce qui l'est
les pirates informatiques criminel russe
était lié au renseignement militaire
russes et lisait la correspondance du
parti démocrate établi ce lien entre les
pirates informatiques et le
renseignement militaire
je ne sais pas donc ça a été ça a été
publié c'était plus aux états unis
ses premiers points le deuxième point
c'est de nos pirates informatiques comme
comme ils le disent très bien l'objectif
qu'ils recherchaient ici c'est une
tentative d'influencer l'opinion
publique dont vous un certain nombre
d'objectifs
donc pour moi c'est tout à fait clair et
je pense que la plupart des lecteurs
comprennent très bien alors ce que je
voulais vous dire à ce propos
il faut ici se référer voler ses devoirs
qui lance de telles campagnes
médiatiques
donc après il ya des gens qui exécutent
simplement mais qui est le commanditaire
qui est le commanditaire de ce genre de
reportage
est-ce que c'est pas de la vengeance est
ce que c'est pas une volonté
d'exclusivité il faut choisir ses
partenaires sur le plan international
parmi ceux qui sont fiables ceux en qui
on peut faire confiance à ce moment là
on peut travailler ensemble pour le bien
de notre pays
ensuite en ce qui concerne le patient de
la clinique berlinoise
j'en ai déjà parlé plusieurs fois et je
ne peux que répéter ce que j'ai déjà dit
peskov justement m'a raconté justement
hier les dernières évolutions de cette
histoire les allégations sur nos
services secrets etc
nous comprenons très bien c'est dans ce
cas comme d'autres c'est la légalisation
c'est pas une enquête c'est un reportage
c'est mais on sait très bien qu'il ya
les systèmes de localisation qui
fonctionne tout le monde le sait très
bien et ce soir les agents du fsb où il
des autres structures certains biens et
ils utilisent leur téléphone lahouze
estiment ils ont pas deux ils n'ont pas
de raison de se cacher mais si c'est
comme ça et c'est ainsi je dirais que ce
patient de la clinique bernoise
il bénéficie de l'appui des services
secrets américains concrètement alors
synthes endroit ça veut dire
qu'effectivement je savais secrets
doivent suivre cette affaire de près
vous comprenez alors l'enquêté peut-être
peut-être pas
achevée il faut la porter son épouse a
demandé à pouvoir le suivre en allemagne
j'ai donné l'autorisation
mais il ya un point ici qui est
important peut-être que le grand public
n'y fait pas attention mais c'est
important quand même le truc résidence
et que l'on s'intéresse aux personnes
les plus importantes on dit voilà mon
partenaire et telle personne donc ça
veut dire que je suis dans la même
catégorie que cette personne
voilà ça veut dire que si je suis face à
des gens importants c'est-à-dire moi
même je suis important
bon là c'est un truc dont la lutte
politique à mon avis il faut pas se
servir de ce genre de trucs pour
acquérir la réputation le respect de la
part de l'opinion publique
il faut pouvoir être jugé sur des choses
concrètes sur les programmes réalistes
et qui puisse être mise en place dans
pays en l'occurrence ici en russie et
donc j'appelle nos oppositions et toutes
les forces politiques dans le pays à se
référer dont pas alors propres ambitions
alors mais aux intérêts du peuple russe
c'est à dire proposer un agenda qui soit
intéressant qui pose des questions
concrètes pour notre pays rostov sur le
don
à vous la parole bonjour monsieur
continue toujours chers collègues nous
sommes ici d'un l'université de
rostov-sur-le-don ici
il y a des gens qui vont travailler
un des étudiants qui ont travaillé
travaillé pour rehausser l'image par
exemple mais aujourd'hui ce sont nos
collègues la journaliste qui sont
présents ici
bonjour si les subtiles j'ai une
question qui est déjà traditionnels pour
vos conférence de presse c'est la
question sur le dôme basse mais pour
notre région c'est une question très
pertinente
présentez vous s'il vous plaît l' agence
d'information dont 24 j'ai une question
sur les perspectives du règlement du
conflit dans le donbass
et selon vous quelles sont les
possibilités du développement des
relations entre la russie et l'ukraine
merci en ce qui concerne les
perspectives de développement des
relations entre la russie et l'ukraine
cela dépend très grande partie des
autorités craignent en elle même c'est à
dire que presque tous les précédents
chefs d'état est aujourd'hui est
actuellement le président vladimir un
gène ce qu'ils appelaient à mettre fin
au conflit dans le combat dans le
donbass
il s'appelait à l'unité du pays et
finalement il voulait avoir de bonnes
relations avec la russie est finalement
rien ne marchait pas ce que quand ils
vous arrivent au pouvoir ils s'appuient
sur la majorité de la population de ceux
qui viennent
[Musique]
participent aux élections et une fois
qu'ils sont au pouvoir
il continue à hésiter et à jeter des
regards
peut-être par manque de courage regarde
les forces nationalistes et donc à ce
moment là le processus s'arrête et c'est
à peu près la même chose qu'on voit
actuellement
heureusement quand on s'est rencontré à
paris dans le cadre du format un
amandier l'accord que nous avons conclu
est respecté et d échange de prisonniers
mais il n'y a rien de débloquer sur le
plan économique et social
rien n'a été fait sur le plan du
règlement politique et de plus les
responsables officiels du livre de kiev
l'on dit publiquement qu'ils nous ont
pas l'intention de respecter les accords
de minsk et envisage même une révision
de ces accords et j'attire votre
attention sur le fait que les accords
2000 ce qu ils ont été confirmées par
une confirmation
ils ont été confirmées par une
résolution du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu ils relèvent d'une loi
internationale donc on ne peut pas
unilatéralement procéder à une révision
de ces accords
quelle que soit cette clé il faut voir
qui a été destinataire et il faut
s'engager vis-à-vis d'eux en
l'occurrence les représentants de dundas
donc le règlement politique se fera un
jour ou l'autre la question de savoir
quand mais en grande partie je le répète
ça dépend des autorités de kiev et la
russie a soutenu le dow basse et nous
allons poursuivre notre soutien d'une
basse nous allons l'augmenter même cela
concerne le soutien de la production
industrielle la résolution des questions
social c'est une aide au niveau des
infrastructures et s'avoue pouvait être
certaine que nous allons poursuivre ce
soutien nous comprenons très bien la
difficulté de cette situation mais je le
répète encore une fois c'est une aide
qui n'est pas seulement humanitaire mais
c'est une question de coopération
directe et ça nous allons poursuivre
nijni novgorod
bonjour monsieur poutine
bonjour mais ce score c'est la capitale
du district fédéral de privilégier les
jeunes auront essayé beaucoup de
journalistes d'un autre studio avec
leurs questions mais en tant que
animateur je voudrais choisir la
question si vous permettez
oui bien sûr journaliste qui veut poser
une question sur le sujet en ligne
bonjour monsieur vous dire je m'appelle
oleg kashtanov je représente les
izvestia de mort de via la ville de
sarrance que j'ai une question sur la
formation à distance formation en ligne
à cette d'un sujet très discuté parce
que au pantin étaient nos écoles et nos
universités ont dû passer un nouvel
système de formation à distance comment
notre système d'enseignement à peu faire
face a pu relever ce défi il ya beaucoup
de questions cet égard le système
d'enseignement de formation à distance
est ce que ce système sera préservée et
à cette époque difficile
est ce qu'il ya une certaine
baisse de qualité de formation y aurait
bien des coeurs aussi maligne faire
comment le partage enseignement à
l'école et aux établissements
d'enseignement supérieur instituts et
universités dans l'ensemble de ses 89 et
1000 écoles et 2% seulement d'entre
elles fonctionner sur le mode en ligne
une partie dans l'autre partie système
avec mx la prison pays continuent de
danser nue quand même avec un supérieur
on recommande à passer à l'enseignement
en ligne pour les écoles pour
l'enseignement secondaire
là j'ai reçu beaucoup de messages
notamment concernant la la disponibilité
technique plus tard déjà pendant des
questions écrit je vous le dirai avec
plus de détails
il y a des problèmes existent sans doute
ça conserve ce qui concerne l'art de
tout le monde n'a pas d'ordinateur chez
soi on a des difficultés de connexion
internet telephony surtout d'aller dans
de petits mais d'en faire deux 2020 6
toulouse 2020 20 ans tout le monde aura
accès à internet haut débit
le système de haut débit d'internet
toutes les écoles pour l'école
supérieure à deux reprises c'était au
moins juillet et en automne nous avons
soutenu ces universités à qui nous avons
alloué des ressources financières que ce
soit pour maintenir leur fonctionnement
en ligne
et annie ils ont élargi leurs capacités
en matière d'enseignement en ligne
le ferons comme tout simplement comme
des agents économiques sans être soutenu
par l'état magne nous les avons déjà
soutenu à deux reprises
quant à la qualité de l'enseignement
bien sûr il était de l'instruction bien
sûr le système en ligne ce format ne
pourra jamais se substituer au contact
direct entre le professeur et l'étudiant
toutes manières falloir attendre très
longtemps donc nous n'allons pas entrer
dans le détail tout le monde le comprend
néanmoins le système dans lequel est à
l'école et à l'université l'enseignement
il sera utilisé bien sûr c'est un
système qui va évoluer je viens de
parler récemment des collègues pour
l'avenir c'est pas toujours un
spécialiste hautement spécialisés de
torpiller vous qui peut être présent
partout en même temps
mais parfois c'est quelqu'un qui fait un
travail plus localisées le mode en ligne
lui donne cette opportunité il faut s'en
servir
on le fait que
tout comme par exemple le système c'est
russe à sotchi que l'on connaît bien cet
établissement d dans d'autres
établissements seraient de plus en plus
utilisés c'est très sollicités cela fait
partie de notre vie
faut pas en avoir peur mais jamais quand
même exagéré c'est possibilité ce n'est
pas pour toute la vie une instruction
aux masses en ligne quant à la qualité
je comprends bien que vous avez une
question il y n qu'est surkis où je
sorte en fait pourra jamais remplacer
des quotas le contact direct et bien sûr
il y a des avantages et des
inconvénients quand on peut écouter par
exemple une sommité scientifique
mondiale m'a peut-être dans le travail
quotidien c'est comment je sais pas ce
n'est pas évident le meilleur l'idéal ce
serait un système mixte il ya un autre
aspect qui puisse aussi bleu je sais que
les étudiants ils vont attention m'a
parfois et s'adressent ils auront
recours aux tribunaux
nous avons payé pour le régime lancées
ima en présentiel je comprends bien ces
étudiants qui ont payé leurs études et
je partage leurs préoccupations mais il
est un autre
robert la médaille quand un professeur
chargé de cours quand il fait une
conférence à tel ou tel autre qui les
lisent que l'élise en ligne ou hors
ligne ou hors ligne
pourquoi supplément s'avère la structure
des dépenses de l'établissement
d'enseignement supérieur 70% quand même
des dépenses
ce sera sa dernière tout simplement les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
ils peuvent réduire
ils n'ont pas les suffisamment de
ressources pour réduire la paie certains
spécialistes estiment que ces relations
sont trop nombreux surtout dans des
villes dans les grands centres du pays
qu'il ya trop de d'écoles supérieures
mais peut-être qu'il faudra les
regrouper c'est une question que les
spécialistes se pose depuis longtemps
bien sûr je pense qu'il faut être
j m d il ne lui offre pas aller trop
vite de l'avant parce que si certaines
écoles peuvent ont les moyens de jouer
avec leurs finances je pense qu'il
faudra accepter la réduction de la paix
des études ou quand ça se fait en ligne
l'état a déjà alloué à deux reprises à
louer défaut donc nous allons continuer
à se comporter de la même manière
maintenant la ville de tula on voit une
fille avec un panneau je suis enceinte
merci bonjour monsieur poutine
alexandra bay joe cole à dorval mk à la
ville de rezaï vladimir vladimirovitch
on entend partout à ce fonctionnaire vol
celui ci est exceptionnel mais je
voudrais vous parler dans fonctionnaires
à un peu différent parce que il y avait
eu un incendie avec une explosion de
notre région très qu'amd incendies et
les localités avoisinantes ont beaucoup
ce faire on était affecté et les idéaux
bus qui volaient partout et beaucoup
d'habitants le coup ne pouvait pas
quitter leurs maisons leurs appartements
et un fonctionnaire a sauvé sept
personnes d'abord et la sauve et de
vieillards impie a été blessée mais est
il est revenu pour sauver une femme et
deux enfants de 8 ans et de cinq mois et
deux autre vieillard
je répète il y avait deux buts qui
volaient partout et les habitants de
notre région ont signé une lettre on
vous demande de lui donner le statut de
héros de la fédération de russie et le
ministre des situations d'urgence
étaient présents là bas sur place et l'a
vu ces situations de ses propres yeux
selon vous monsieur grekov doit-il être
reconnu
comme euros parce qu'elle a sauvé les
vies des gens il a risqué sa vie
je veux répondre à vos trucs et sur le
gel qui commence c'est lié au fait que
vous vous êtes enceinte à monsieur
poutine une petite histoire à en 2019 je
suis venu à votre conférence de presse
deux semaines avant et depuis deux
semaines après j'ai donné la vie à nos
enfants et cette fois j'ai décidé de
prendre ce panneau avec cette écriture
et vous nous avez berne et voilà qu'on
sert à igorre gréco bien sûr c'est un
acte héroïque quelqu'un en temps de paix
qui a risqué sa vie pour sauver la vie
des autres bien sûr il a mérité une
récompense au niveau national nous
allons réfléchir aux tirs mais le fait
de l'avoir signalé sa charge
je vous en remercie sincèrement vous
êtes quelqu'un de très attentifs vous
êtes quelqu'un de très attentive et cela
vous honore et vos enfants sur vos
grandir dans une excellente atmosphère
dont je vous souhaite beaucoup de succès
donc nous n'oublierons pas y of mercy
maladie murs latéraux je tiens à
souligner que le forum aux nefs il
devait avoir lieu cette année mais puis
elle a été suspendue et à mon collègue a
envoyé une vidéo pour ce forum est
maintenant il a été mis en ligne tout le
monde critique mon collègue mais nos
collègues doivent comprendre que si on
envoie une vidéo avec un problème très
important
et si avant le forum ce problème a
médiatisé c'est un peu risqué
je ne comprends pas pourquoi
il y a il a eu la été victime de
beaumont parce qu'il a parlé du central
de nouveaux rezaï
parce que c'est monopoliste et je ne
sais pas à qui et comment a pu publier
cette vidéo en ligne parce que mon
collègue et à la seule personne qui ait
avait cette vidéo est donc cette vidéo a
été publiée en ligne
et puis le journaliste kara au love à
publier les vidéos il a reçu bien
évidemment l'argent pour publier
d'autres vidéos avec les critiques avec
des mensonges et kelly à des critiques
personnelles à perdre mais moi je pense
que le volontaire va écouter vous n'avez
pas d'eau il a écrit à propos de la
centrale thermique de novara than mon
collègue qui se trouve à côté
ainsi si vous permettre de répondre à
toutes ces questions pourrait lui donner
le micro
s'il vous plaît bonjour en tonneau 109
rédacteur en chef de la ville de rason
un des vainqueurs du concours national
on nage ici ce propos d'un sujet vidéo
une vidéo consacrée aux problèmes liés à
la centrale thermique de rosen ses films
que je n'avais que et l'organisation du
front populaire de berlin qui a été qui
est paru d'abord sur les réseaux sociaux
et ça ma volonté est là je suis traité
je suis insulté
et on m'accuse de corruption de mais
vous êtes rompu partie intense je
n'avais pas comprendre qu'ils appuient
vous accusé de corruption parce que vous
luttez pour les intérêts des citoyens
qui pourraient vous êtes suédé couru de
vous accuser de corruption vous n'avez
en posant de personne ni tué ni vous
n'avez en pause et m'a dit tu es bien
personnes qu'est-ce que vous avez vendu
qu est ce qu on vous accuse de vendre on
estime que je suis est juste ma critique
est injuste de la centrale thermique de
nouveaux réseaux vous rendrez compte que
votre métier est lié à certains risques
il ya des risques du métier qui sont au
rendez vous et c'est bien le contraire
cette réaction aussi forte qu'en vous à
sua fille accuse de curieux qui vous est
dans la bonne voie
non seulement quant à la centrale
thermique je sais pas où est le problème
je n'ai pas lu vos articles je
demanderai à mes collègues haddock 2
ça m'occupe c'est une centrale privée ou
non c'est un organisme privé qui loue
des capacités de production de la ville
des roses abri où je demanderai des
collègues qui ils fassent attention je
vous remercie d'avoir signalé ce fait et
wam a du courage moi c'est pas du jeu
n'a rien d'extraordinaire c'est la vie
voilà on lui ont écrit tous heures de
queue de couvrir mon sujet ben oui quoi
que ça fait bon mot chance bon courage
concertla igor grekov il a été acquis
quelle était sa fonction il est
fonctionnaire mais les fonctionnaires en
quoi peut-on redonner la parole à sacha
tous là qu'elles sont un emploi lice
gouverneur de la région de raisin je
l'offre papier voilà la région de
léningrad vol sauf vaud
quel écho bagdad où les nicolas est
l'auteur de ce message c'était un
dialogue avec un des fonctionnaires de
la région qui lui dit quand une question
c'est poutine qui vous l'a promise c'est
un petit que vous demandez moi je n'ai
rien prenait ainsi il dit pourquoi les
fonctionnaires dans leurs bureaux
régionaux se comporte de cette manière
oui ça existe
[Musique]
cher anatolie johathan attiré autant te
sauter ce qu'a dit la journée ça il y à
d'autres fonctionnaires comme ceux igor
grekov et il ya ceux qui ont su écouter
dans chaque milieu
au nord il ya parfois des brebis
galeuses qui vous a dit qui vous a
traité d'une manière aussi
un goujat on le je demanderai aux
gouverneurs qu'il contacte avec ou et
pour qu'ils prennent des décisions au
niveau du perron de son personnel de sa
maîtresse pour s'il vous plaît bonjour
monsieur possible pour le jour monsieur
peskov
je vous salue ici à saint-pétersbourg
ici nous avons les journalistes de de
l'ensemble de notre industrie nous avons
des panneaux très modeste
et puis je choisir le journaliste j'aime
beaucoup la question dieu journalistes
d'un journal qui veut savoir quand les
frontières sont intel ou verte
j'ai déjà lu votre question c'est une
question bonjour monsieur poutine qui a
réussi neuf as journal de pékin quand
les frontières seront elles ouvertes
vous savez qu'il ya quelques semaines
notre ville a été reconnue ou là le
meilleur centre touristique d'importance
internationale nous avons dépassé des
concurrents tels concurrents que le
paris new york rendu par exemple mais
aujourd'hui le problème de l'ouverture
des frontières et c'est considérable
pour les revenus parce que nous savons
que les travaux sont en cours pour
lancer le renouveler mais brawl d'avion
et il ya des pays qui n'ont pas souvent
visitée mais nous avons quand même
renouveler les vols mais dans notre
structure de revenus le secteur
touristique
cette industrie elle souffre et les
toucher et bien sûr la pandémie joue un
rôle important mais est-ce qu'il ya
quand même une possibilité d'ouvrir les
frontières dans le meilleur délai kirill
vous comme moi nous aimons saint
pétersbourg je pense que la plupart des
habitants du pays aime beaucoup cette
ville qui est notre ville natale et ce
qui nous unis ont pas encore été je
souhaite d'y aller c'est effectivement
une des plus belles capitales au monde
et évidemment c'est un point
d'attraction c'est un aimant pour
l'activité touristique il ya la question
de fréquentation des visites notamment
en bateau et nous essayons de créer
d'autres infrastructures favorable au
développement du tourisme à saint
pétersbourg donc donc félicitations à
saint-pétersbourg pour cette victoire à
ce concours international et cette
victoire tout à fait méritée et c'est
difficile d'une richesse architecturale
mais le mondial avec les plus grands
noms des architectes rastrelli et
résignés etc
mais ce que je veux dire que saint
pétersbourg certains se vendent
aujourd'hui c'est une ville qui propose
de un nouveau contexte favorable
avec des infrastructures adaptées et
tout cela est important donc c'est un
site qui est beau il ya des sites
sportifs
il y a le centre sportif des sports mme
arena par exemple et je saint
pétersbourg est une ville qui accueille
des compétitions plus haut niveau tout à
fait satisfaisant et tout cela
évidemment attire l'attention sur la
ville évidemment personne n'a
l'intention de l'imiter aujourd'hui le
taux de morteau de morbidité avec le
cannabis à saint pétersbourg c'est quoi
c'est surtout s est élevée c'est pour ça
que les restrictions ont été imposées
dans la région oui ben justement c'est
là qu'est la question le problème de la
charge de deux lits d'hôpitaux je crois
qu'on est à 25% et à saint-pétersbourg
est à 24 5% c'est plus élevé que ça donc
évidemment ici elle question de la santé
des seins plus tard je vous vois et je
pense que dès que la situation sanitaire
le permettra les frontières seront
ouvertes
bien entendu nous voudrions que nos
citoyens les citoyens de la fédération
aussi profitent de cette possibilité de
développer le tourisme en interne ans un
duo pays lui-même qu'il vient à saint
pétersbourg et là y'a pas besoin de vie
évidemment de vrd des frontières je suis
bien conscient que le tourisme est un
des secteurs qui a le plus souffert
c'est le transport aérien et on se sens
c'est très important
nous espérons qu'il y aura la
possibilité effectivement que les gens
puissent
venir et que nos compagnies aériennes
pourront effectuer des liaisons
aériennes avec d'autres pays ça fait 35
milliards de dollars de bénéfices
d'activités touristiques pour être
réorientés
sur les activités intérieures et saint
pétersbourg mérite effectivement et
cette attention du secteur du tourisme
et je pense que nous pouvons
effectivement faire beaucoup et dès que
ce sera possible nous ouvrirons les
frontières maintenant les journalistes
qui sont dans la salle avec monsieur
poutine
la chaîne pervyi kanal
s'il vous plaît
micro bonjour constaté paniouchkine la
chaîne pervyi kanal
je voudrais me souvenir de l'époque
avant j'attendais dit qu'on n'avait pas
dû gérer ces questions personnellement
vous avez parlé du dynamisme et le
gouvernement de l'ue justin a été créé
pour attendre cet objectif maintenant la
mise en oeuvre des objectifs projets
nationaux cela a été suspendu mais
monsieur koudrine a dit que les projets
nationaux ne pouvait pas contribuer à
atteindre les objectifs jusqu'à l'année
2009 1,4 selon vous est ce que le
gouvernement de me justice ne peut
réussir à atteindre ses objectifs dans
les dans ces délais qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
nous avons des objectifs stratégiques
qui n'ont pas disparu ils sont toujours
d'actualité et bien entendu
l'infection à cornebarrieu apporter des
modifications des amendements ça c'est
clair
c'est ce que j'ai déjà dit
donc le premier maillon de développement
de la chaîne sanitaire a dû être
accélérées au compteur nous avions
besoin évidemment de ressources pour
cela et il a fallu donc réaffecter les
budgets il a fallu travailler d'autres
pays apporter des aides à l'extérieur il
a fallu développer notre secteur
ici en interne rien que pour le soutien
à la population
nous avons envoyé plus de 800 milliards
de roubles et nous avons dû concentrer
ses ressources
précisément dans ce secteur médical et
sanitaire mais aussi les secteurs qui
ont souffert de la crise de la pandémie
mais en tout cas les objectifs
stratégiques n'ont pas été annulées
n'ont pas été modifiées le gouvernement
travaille de façon satisfaisante
on a parlé des prix et votre chaîne à
montrer justement édifier une autre
discussion avec certains membres du
gouvernement sur cette question et je
pense que certains membres du
gouvernement n'ont pas réagi de façon
suffisamment rapide mais dans le
contexte de cette pandémie le
gouvernement a travaillé dans un
contexte de charges très importantes et
de façon tout à fait satisfaisante
[Musique]
je le remercie pour les efforts qui ont
été consentis ici ensuite nous sommes
les amendements ce sont des initiatives
qui reviennent au gouvernement et il a
consenti adopter certaines modifications
dans les plans vois qu'ici le le
personnel gouvernement travaille de
façon coordonnée
ici il faut maintenir une certaine
stabilité
je dis ça pour répondre à votre question
il n'ya pas de changements prévus ici
dans la composition novembre encore une
fois le travail l'activité qui a été
menée correspond aux objectifs qui
avaient été fixés et nous suivons ses
objectifs je le répète encore une fois
tout clairement définis les critiques
ont été émises au début ça qu'ils sont
de savoir si nous serons capable ou pas
bhl de d'honorer ses objectifs il faut
savoir que bien sûr il y à des questions
qui méritent d'être
étudier de façon un peu plus approfondie
mais dans l'ensemble les régions ont
mises en pratique les programmes qu'ils
avaient été identifiés et notamment bon
cette attribution ses affects
d'affectation de budgétaire donc tout
suit le plan fixé il continue encore une
chose simplement j'avais on donnait la
parole à cette jeune fille s'il vous
plaît c'est le griffant nova ladmirault
l'a dit mais robiche les amendements à
la constitution cette année pourquoi
vous savez tout chaque chose en son
temps
la lutte contre la hausse des prix elle
a fait le lève et la famine g8 modifier
la constitution plutôt ça aurait été
difficile ou impossible il ya une base
fondamentale des 609 constitution qui
n'a pas été modifiée c'est la
constitution de 1993 qui avait adopté
dans une situation qui était difficile
il y avait eu des combats dans la
capitale à moscou des gens sont morts
des armes automatiques avaient été
utilisés et dans ces conditions les
chars avaient tiré et c'est dans ces
conditions difficiles que la
constitution a été adoptée
donc on va pas effacer de notre mémoire
ces événements et que ce n'était pas
n'importe où ici à moscou dans une
constitution avait été adoptée à
l'époque dans ces conditions et elle a
joué un rôle stabilisateur
elle a permis de restaurer la paix
civile et à la constituent et donc une
base pour l'évolution le développement
politique du pays aujourd'hui la
situation est différente et conformément
à cette situation nouvelle nous avons dû
modifier apporter des amendements à
cette constitution
il ya des choses que nous ne pouvions
pas envisager plutôt par exemple les
garanties sociales par exemple
l'indexation des retraites en 1993 comme
on aurait pu écrire ça à l'époque
notamment l'obligation de l'état
vis-à-vis de ces paiements de retraite
ça aurait été impossible puisque l
époque avait même pas de retraite il y
avait beaucoup de de nos horaires qui
était pas payer de salaire aujourd'hui
la situation est différente aujourd'hui
il faut éviter que les responsables
politiques ne remplissent pas cette
obligation parce qu'aujourd'hui la
réalité économique elle nous permet
d'honorer ses obligations
[Musique]
c'est la même chose avec au niveau de la
lutte contre la pauvreté
c'est bien qu'il ya beaucoup de familles
rue s'était dit pas votre collègue
aujourd'hui qu'ils vivent difficilement
le montant du salaire minimum ne peut
pas être en dessous du minimum vital ça
c'est clair
est-ce qu'on peut le faire oui je pense
qu'on peut faire donc tout cela et est
aujourd'hui fixée dans la constitution
il y à d'autres problèmes qui s'opposent
je préfère aux questions qui sont posées
bon on voit par exemple le salaire
d'enseignant qui correspondent pas au
niveau du minimum vital des gens qui
n'ont pas eu d'augmentation de salaire
alors qu'il aurait dû en avoir une
encore une fois encore une fois le le
salaire minimum ne peut pas être
inférieurs au minimum vital donc là il
ya des efforts qui sont faits et
aujourd'hui on a des exigences qui sont
formulées dans la constitution
aujourd'hui on parle des priorités du
droit constitutionnel notamment la
prééminence du droit constitutionnel
russe sur les textes internationaux il
ya l'intangibilité du territoire c'est
un ace qu'en 1993 on pouvait le formule
2 1 oui on peut dire ce qu'on veut ici
oui on aura pu l'écrire mais est-ce
qu'on aurait été capable de l'assuré
c'est pas certain donc aujourd'hui on
avait à l'époque l'ensemble de l'armée
russe qui était quasiment effondré et
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme
international dans coca on n'arrive même
pas à réunir 50000 baïonnette à l'époque
aujourd'hui la situation est différente
aujourd'hui nos opposants comme je dis
ils sont moins nombreux mais ils sont
bien plus efficaces
on a aujourd'hui une des armes il
désormais les plus efficaces au monde
donc cela peut aujourd'hui être stipulé
clairement dans la constitution
nous pouvions le faire et au moment le
moment venu de l'avant faire d'ailleurs
à propos des amendements il y avait
complété
donc on avait des centaines de milliers
de propositions d'amendements qui était
venu et je remercie tous ceux qui ont
participé à ce débat
cette discussion est notamment ensuite
après référendum donc il ya une
participation qui était avec très
importante donc
c'était dans les faits c'est un
référendum sur un projet dont l'auteur
en fait et l ensemble de la population
russe et cela est important et je tiens
encore une fois exprimer ma gratitude
envers les citoyens de notre pays qui
ont soutenu cet amendement stapro paul
s'esclaffe aux pôles
c'est la jeune sud tout comme à la
région de rostov sur le don parce que
j'ai pratiquement le point situé salle
c'est une autre point qui se trouvent
dans notre région et les journalistes
sont présents ici pour poser la question
si vous me permettez monsieur que ce
code je tiens à choisir qui va poser la
première question peut-être à cette
belle femme peut-être vous au centre
pouvez poser votre question
merci désherbinage shirts sauvage
je représente
le service d'information de lutter car
alagna
bien sûr nous sommes tous préoccupés par
la pandémie par le cos vite 19 parce que
la pandémie a touché l'ensemble de nos
secteurs et tout d'abord le secteur de
la santé publique et même avant la
pandémie
ce secteur était marquée par les
salaires assez bas et par les réformes
despotisme et une région ont commencé à
examiner leurs priorités revoir leurs
priorités est tout d'abord il s'agit du
développement de tourisme tourisme
intérieur dans notre pays
qu'est ce que vous en pensez monsieur
poutine en ce qui concerne le soutien
accordé à ce secteur de l'économie qui
dans de nouveaux pays contribuent
considérablement au budget par exemple
la turquie là elle il ya beaucoup de la
location pour soutenir le secteur du
tourisme et notre région le stif d'une
heure étaient toujours connus par ses
seins thorium et aujourd'hui nous avons
toutes les conditions pour développer le
tourisme par exemple tourisme
gastronomique et dans ce type de
tourisme
mais il ya un problème problèmes
d'infrastructures et sans soutien au
niveau fédéral on ne peut pas les
résoudre sans merci
nous avons déjà commencé par dire zeri
la serna saint pétersbourg où on attend
l'ouverture des frontières pour
l'arrivée du d'études de touristes
étrangers vous avez entendu donc une
partie de ma réponse qui est lié au fait
que car mon avis c'est très important
laissez nos concitoyens qui ont pris
l'habitude de passer leurs vacances à
l'étranger trop de 32 millions qui
passaient leurs vacances à l'étranger
mais il est tout aussi important de
développer le tourisme à intérieur cette
année nous essayons de le faire
n'importe quel bien pour le retour de
l'argent qu'ils étaient payés pour fait
qu'on a payé pour les voyages à
l'étranger qu'ils n'ont pas eu lieu pour
la restriction de forbin ce que nous
avons prévu pour ce qu'est ce que ce 15
milliards de roubles
nous avons utilisé dépensé seulement 1,2
milliard il a été convenu avec le
gouvernement
cet argent nous n'allons pas leur
distribuer nous allons qui les aident
avec un motant les années prochaines
et nous allons à main
accroître ce service tout simplement
pour ne pas être d informer donc je
m'adresse à vous à vos collègues des
médias celui qui surtout il faut
soutenir le développement du tourisme
intérieur et de montrer plus souvent les
les possibilités qui existent en russie
dans les différentes régions pour nos
concitoyens pour des étrangers également
bien sûr je comprends très bien je vois
ce qu'ils disent c'est tellement ce si
beau meliani divin c'est dit
in you potable ni restauration
les housses sont infranchissables cela
demande du temps et bien sûr des
dépenses
ennahda départ c'est normal mais nous
allons investir l'argent dans la
structure des business qui sauront
qu'ils sont efficaces l'état doit bien
sûr soutenir un portrait sans son
concours au niveau des infrastructures
et nous allons bien sûr est consacrée
défaut qui seront prévus
nous allons soutenir le business dans
son ensemble dans la région la structure
qui va s'occuper l'institution qui va
s'occuper du tourisme intérieur
hier je parlais à dmitry chernyshenko
vice-premier ministre responsable du
secteur il s'étale que ce serait
effectivement c'est vous avez dans votre
parti nous savons quel point c'est
important pour l'état tout entière vous
avez parlé de turquie et à côté je
reconstruis pendant des dizaines
d'années ils ont construit tout un
système
l état a toujours massivement soutenu ce
secteur ce n'est pas une déception la
règle j'ai déjà cité cet exemple le mois
des constructions navales à la corée du
sud a construit tout système de soutien
des de subsides notamment au niveau
fiscal bien sûr tout était normalisé
petit à petit zoo des navires de gros
tonnage quiconque ils construisent en
corée du sud
pareil en turquie conserva le domaine
touristique
nous allons avancer dans cette direction
mais les photos qui ont été prévues les
15 milliards de roubles
nous allons les remettre pour l'année
prochaine
ça fait déjà plus de deux heures je vous
invite à placer vos masques
tu ne veux pas demain ce coeur qu'on
annonce que tout ça attendez moi de mes
frères pour simplement pour diluer les
une question qu'on sera internet et de
possibilité d'étudier en ligne beaucoup
de questions
la qualité d'être télécommunications et
d'accès internet c'est d'une grande
actualité pour ceux qui font leurs
études de comprend bien que pour les
écoles en 2021 nous allons introduire
internet à haut débit partout dans
toutes les écoles hélas ce qui est très
important c'est que dans les différentes
localités jusqu'à 200 en 2001 21 il
faudra assurer un système de
communication interne atteint pour les
localités de plus de 200 milles
jusqu'à sa famille d'habitat je veux pas
citer il ya beaucoup de questions à ce
sujet mais dans ces localités
il ya parfois des questions comique bas
on voit pas grave c'est au moins grimper
sur les arbres mais jusqu'à la fin de
l'année dans ces localités il faudra
résoudre ce problème définitivement que
nous avons consacré 12,6 milliards de
roubles prévu dans le budget est je
pense qu'il se ces fonds seront mises en
valeur de façon à faire sentir aux
habitants la qualité des
télécommunications là pour les plus
petites localités mais on continuera à
le faire mieux à votre dictateur est
quand même âge dans la parole à un tv la
chaîne télé le micro journalistes il au
québec la chef qu'est la chaîne ntv g
oui j'ai questions sur la politique
extérieure sur nos soi-disant
partenaires occidentaux pendant ces
derniers 4,1 selon vous qui parmi les
dirigeants internationaux et est le plus
confortable le plus difficile comme
négociateur parce que je me souviens une
fois vous avez donné une leçon de
géographie à madame merkel monsieur
mâcon sur le l'incident dans l'argile de
cartes et jeux vous avez évoqué donald
trump on a évoqué au cimetière de blanc
et monsieur loukachenko je pense que
louis si c'est un partenaire intéressant
et une autre question sur le projet nord
stream 2 les états unis exercent une
pression sans précédent sur les pays
européens et l'europe notamment
l'allemagne
c'est de lutter contre cette pression en
question des perspectives concernant les
partenaires agréable plus ou moins écrit
ça n'existe pas il est je n'ai pas
besoin de donneurs de sang qui que ce
soit tout ce sceau des personnes
expérimentées triés sur le volet
adéquatement préparer tout le monde
cherche à régler des problèmes qui se
poseront leur pays mais par des moyens
différents mais quand même c'est certain
ce qui t'a pas de bon ni de mauvais il y
a des intérêts nationaux
pour moi c'est pareil je ne fais pas de
division entre deux mauvais sujet est
beau sujet je travaille avec tout le
monde pour atteindre le résultat maximum
pour la russie parfois il faut aller à
des couples consentir des compromis à
lier il faut insister sur sa position
sur françois début cela arrive tous
leurs tout le reste n'est pas productif
n'est pas efficace
vous avez mentionné certains pays pas
tous à tous les pays avec qui nous avons
des relations comme importante mais il
ya la chine nous avons des intérêts
concordants sur bien des domaines
peut-être ça il ya d'autres liens
d'autres fluides au niveau personnel
cela est dû au fait que je de très
bonnes relations aux relations
d'affaires professionnels mais à la fois
très confiante avec le président xi
jinping est ce là ce qui est des
considérablement dans mon travail
nous avons bien sûr des vues divergentes
s'il avère le président r de gannan mais
parfois nous avons des points de vue
opposés
c'est quelqu'un qui qui tient parole
c'est un homme il ne fait pas
j'étais avec eux quand ils estiment que
c'est dans l'intérêt de son pays il va
jusqu'au bout
cette année les modes ces quelques geeks
et de prévisible c'est très important
pour savoir à qui on a affaire et je
pense que pour north stream de ce gazon
ce gazoduc c'est qu'elle est absolument
évident c'est comme deux font quatre
c'est intéressant c'est profitable pour
l'économie de l'europe dans son ensemble
est pour l'allemagne en particulier
une autre variante l'achat de gaz
liquéfiés liquéfie américain au prix
quai 2 20% plus avec le gaz conduite ça
diminue les possibilités qu la
compétitivité de l'économie allemande
est plus grands prix pour les ménages
ce sont des choses évidentes on n'a pas
besoin d'être et que gazier ou
économistes pour y voir clair c
correspond aux intérêts nationaux des
pays d'europe et de l'allemagne
à ce jour les représentants de
l'économie allemande et nous avons
beaucoup d'amis
ce joli centre et son cabas parmi des
dirigeants politiques de la rfa qui est
sec à main parce que c'est une question
sont des questions ce congé purement
économique mais qui se meurt position
est ouverte qui soutiennent ouvertement
ce projet de nord stream 2 il reste 60
km à construire en une file pour une
voie pour un gazoduc 160 au total c'est
pratiquement achevée je pense que nous
allons on
terminait ses ouvrages et la nouvelle
administration va traiter ses
partenaires cezelly avec respect et va
pas assister pour qu'ils négligent leurs
intérêts nationaux et retourne d'un
régime d'une coupure d'une compétition
loyale sur les marchés mondiaux et
j'espère que ce projet finira par être
réalisés ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas
donné la parole aux journalistes du
centre d'appels oui en quoi que vous
avez oublier que nous sommes ici à ici
il ya beaucoup de questions est le
nombre augmente parce que vous pouvez
poser votre question sur les
applications c'est spécial ici vous
pouvez envoyer votre vidéo ou votre
message par écrit ici il y à des
volontaires dans un pc achat pc negev
pendant la pandémie il a analysé il a
traité plus de 19000 de questions en
question avec les russes ou sacha j'ai
reçu beaucoup de questions sur les
allocations les mesures de soutien
surtout des hummer les citoyens sont
très intéressés par la question de
savoir s'il y aura de nouvelles
allocution par exemple dans la région
d'arkhangelsk de tambour et dans
beaucoup d'autres régions les gens ne
savent pas ce qu'ils peuvent toucher ou
aller par exemple à moscou on dit que
les centres multifonctionnels ne trouve
pas très bien parce que les gens ne
peuvent pas envoyer leur demande parce
que ces centres sont fermés à cause du
courant d'un virus est automatiquement
ce service ne marche pas le site ne
marche pas elle gens ne savent pas où
aller et c'est la question très
importante mais ce putin en 2021 est ce
que
il y aura de l'allocution
supplémentaires l'allocution de
maternité pour les enfants parce que
c'est un problème en tout temps et le se
souciant est très considérable en ce qui
concerne les allocations pour enfants je
vais parler en détail de 0 à 18 mois de
18 mois à 3 ans et à toi de 3 à 7 ans
j'en ai parlé au début ainsi les jo
c'est vrai ça vous pose la question où
il faut s'adresser quand quand on a des
problèmes je pense que avant de
s'interroger sur ce qu'il faut faire en
plus c'est ce que je viens de dire
seulement il y à d'autres formes de
soutien à l'enfance pour des régions
selon la situation démographique dans
chaque région particulière qui ont leur
propre mode opératoire il faut avoir
travaillé efficacement
là où il ya des choses qui sont en place
et je demanderai aux représentants de
président-délégué du président dans les
régions et au gouverneur ça se fait par
le faux des pensions par les services
par les fonctionnaires je vous remercie
vous l'a dit cela devrait avoir attiré
l'attention ce poids que vous avez que
vous réagissez aux demandes des citoyens
je vous remercie de cette initiative
c'est très important le travail que tu
parlais bénévoles et volontaires nous
avons parlé en personne nos concitoyens
merci pour
c'est bizarre comme
et bam source c'est inquiétant que des
personnes qui n'arrivent pas à ukiah
faire valoir leurs doigts ceux qui
s'adressent à vous je nous allons réagir
à leurs études et à ce titre là il ya
beaucoup de questions concernant le
système de soins de santé publique
par exemple le territoire de l'altaï la
fermeture de l'hôpital de l'itie données
gadonneix s'est il s'agit ceci dit
natalia du provigo va céder ses nature
les habitants qui paniquent à ce sujet
je bois je vous le promets et je tire la
tension ceux du gouverneur du territoire
altaï et dernier de la présidence
ce sont des choses qui arrivent souvent
l'établissement médical d'enseignement
dans une petite petite localité à le
faire pour des raisons de rentabilité
mais quand il ya vu l'immensité de notre
territoire
il faut en tenir compte les gens ne
savent pas où aller enterrer kolesnikov
à vous la parole votre question bonjour
je représente le journal kommersant
valentina terechkova a proposé d'ajouter
dans la constitution l'article sur
la remise à zéro des de vos mandats donc
en 2024 vous pouvez être relu et qu'est
ce que cela veut dire
êtes vous prêts à le faire ou vous ne
voulez pas devenir ans linda cas comme
on dit de quoi pensez vous quand vous
avez soutenu cette idée parce que pour
moi et pour beaucoup d'autres gens
c'était une mesure assez redoutable
quand il s'agit là de la constitution
est ce que cela vaut la peine y est
maintenant notre notre deuxième question
notre journaliste débutant nous a dit
qu'il faut poser de questions il ya
quelques jours vous vous exprimer sur la
sphère yvan safronov s'ils prenaient les
informations des sources ouvertes donc
il ne peut pas être accusé
mais est ce que vous avez réussi
d'apprendre les détails de cette affaire
quelles étaient les sources
d'information divan safonov et peut-être
on utilise très souvent ces accusations
ces accusations très
dur et si on suggère par exemple parce
que hier on a reçu les informations
plusieurs médias ont publié les
informations selon lesquelles ils
obtenaient leur se veut raisonné des
sources ouvertes si on dit qu'il
resterait ces informations peut être
c'était son dec en échec peut-être c'est
peut-être une situation où il ne
comprenait pas ce qu'il faisait et
peut-être dans cette situation on peut
pardonner vent je le connais très bien
et je connaissais très bien son père qui
était une personne parfaitement honnête
et je suis sûr que illva saronno ne va
pas répéter cet échec
et s'il répète cet échec on va à
répondre ensemble mais pas mais pas avec
vous ou pas avec les gains sont en ce
qui concerne la question de savoir s'il
fallait dans de ce qu'il fallait faire
dans le cadre de
l'amendement à la constitution en
répondant à cette question c'est ma
règle générale il faut voir est-ce que
ce que nous faisons va améliorer la
situation de populations ou pas si c'est
oui alors faisons le
ma décision concernant les élections c
est ce que j'irai ou pas je sais pas
mais pour la stabilité du pays
oui formellement cette décision l aide
de la part de la population
après est-ce qu'on ira où est-ce qu'on
n'ira pas en ce qui concerne safronov
est-ce qu'il a pris des informations de
ressources publiques c'est à l'anc est
de déterminer
il n'est pas jugé andré vous savez bien
il n'est pas jugé pour son activité
journalistique c'est le sens de tout ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui
c'est par un journaliste dissident qui
cherchent à conquérir le pouvoir et qui
est con et qu'on attrape être qu'on met
en prison s'est passé c'est pas lié à
son activité professionnelle
cette affaire est liée à un travail
qu'il a fait pendant un certain temps
assez long en cas ou dans qualité
d'adjoint de rogozine roskosmos c'est
pas du tout à son activité de
journaliste
vous avez dit qu'il aurait pu faire une
erreur oui ça arrive
oui on sait ce serait pardonnable oui il
faut voir le niveau de dangerosité de ce
qui les fait c'est à dire quels dommages
qu'il a causés
donc on l'accuse d'espionnage de
trahison nationale
mais le plus grave c'est la trahison de
la transmission d'informations
confidentielles ça c'est une trahison et
je comprends bien que désagréable
entendre pour ceux qui le connaissent et
qu'ils ont une bonne opinion de lui je
compatis envers ses amis nous mêmes mais
si pendant un certain temps il a
consciemment réuni un certain nombre
d'informations
et qu'il a transmis cela c'est quand
même révélateur de son état d'esprit
intérieur encore une fois c'est la cour
qui doit déterminer lors du procès son
degré de responsabilité
ensuite le lui pardonner ou ou le punir
ça c'est l'étape suivante mais il est
encore trop tôt pour le dire
on continue ici dans cette salle je peux
être à une question sur le sport match
tv merci merci monsieur poutine oil gas
beau gosse losc à la chaîne match serré
mais tout d'abord je tiens à vous
remercier à voir pour nous avoir
il a félicité à l'occasion d'une autre
centième anniversaire
vous avez apprécié notre travail merci
nous sommes reconnaissants ma question
aux portes en partie ce le sport mais
les sujets beaucoup plus vaste je parle
de la situation dans laquelle s'est
retrouvée il ya quelques semaines un
footballeur arthur du bas une vidéo
personnelle a été publié en ligne et
cela pour qu'il y ait une grande des
réactions publiques toutes les médias en
discuter de cette situation que
quelqu'un était sympathisant quelqu'un
critiquer mais on comprend que ce sont
les pirates informatiques qui ont publié
cette vidéo on ne l'a pas fait lui même
ce sont les gens malhonnêtes et je dis
que c'est une question qui est liée au
sport uniquement en partie parce que
dans cette situation vie c'est un
athlète qui à se faire en football heure
mais tout le monde peut se retrouver
dans une situation pareille et est ce
que ces situations peut avoir une
influence sur le métier de chacun sa
réponse est claire évidemment il ne doit
pas y avoir d'interférence ici entre les
deux c'est à dire qui est qu'ils se
key résolve ces questions personnelles
mais bien évidemment les discussions sur
la vie personnelle de n'ont pas lieu
d'être
dans le champ public et de la mesure que
c'est une personnalité publique
évidemment c'était inévitable mais pour
lui comme pour les gens qui vivent au vu
du public cette jeunesse est une leçon
il vous faut le garder à l'esprit après
il ya une règle générale à laquelle il
faut se dire c'est tout est ce que cela
doit se refléter sur sa vie
professionnelle bien sûr que non à ce
propos enfin bon de toute façon j'ai
vous l'avez vu cette vidéo à vous savez
monsieur poutine je pense que tout le
monde à notre pays à regarder cette
vidéo moi je ne vais pas regarder
jusqu'à la fin mais dès le début c'est
clair j'ai pas vu donc moi j'ai pas
regardé donc je lis est différente
différents messages qui me sont adressés
notamment par l'intermédiaire du centre
d'appels krasinski de la région de
montry parle de l'ambiance c'est le
village de lacour pied il dit que nous
avions avant qu'une ambulance avec un
infirmier pour tout le village
on peut aller évidemment soi même par
ses propres moyens
si on y arrive jusqu'à la clinique mai
et là on n'a qu'un médecin généraliste
et ma grand mère qui a 87 ans qui a déjà
du mal à distinguer l'angine de la
sinusite donc un prime de transport et
de suivi médical
à ce propos je voudrais donc dire cher
du riz que c'est effectivement c'est le
cas et que votre grand mère qui
travaille comme infirmière sur place et
que c'est une c'est une ancienne c'est
un lé vétéran et elle mérite tout le
respect ça veut dire que l continuelle
et à son poste
donc elle a vu sa formation médicale à
l'époque soviétique était très élevé
d'ailleurs comme à l'époque l'état
voulait l'aider mais si elle a du mal à
distinguer ces deux maladies il faut
peut-être l'aider qu'elle perd pas de
temps il faut peut-être l'aider mais il
faut la soutenir et nous nous allons
essayer de vous soutenir de vous aider
le déjà dit que nous avons passé des
commandes
grâce à un budget affecté spécialement
pour acheter du matériel des véhicules
donc il ya au niveau des gouvernements
et au niveau régional des gouverneurs et
des autorités qu'il ne municipal il ya
des instructions qui est un adam qu'il
faut ici un travail de maintenance du
matériel d'ambulances et nous allons
bien évidemment vous aider à vous la
parole et le fêtard vladivostok
bonjour oui vraiment déjà presque 1000
juristes sont très intéressés il ya
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé par donner moi
vous êtes tous très bons spécialistes
mais je tiens à donner la parole à la
femme qui porte le panneau la politique
et les gens merci l'agent de ce prime un
média oksana qui se lover je crois que
l'anonyme 2020 sur un marqué non
seulement par la pandémie qui explique
pour toutes les régions mais aussi par
le nouveau gouverneur dans plusieurs
régions par exemple le crado khabarovsk
et la situation dans cette région a été
très remarquable non seulement pour les
habitants de cette région qui ont
soutenu leur ancien gouverneur messieurs
four dalle mais il ya eu aussi des
manifestations dans les régions de
magasins sakhaline kamtchatka et
d'autres régions un monsieur poutine et
les quelques jours votre représentant
plénipotentiaire excellent lien il y
aurait entre eux tenir à 10 ha
dans une interview que malgré
cette base issue de beaucoup de gens a
fort galles et il a échoué à remplir sa
mission et il était difficile de
coopérer avec fort galles j'ai une
question à vous est ce que vous avez de
nouvelles informations des services
enquête qui pourrait confirmer la
gravité des accusations et en ce qui
concerne les manifestations de
protestation est ce que vous entendez
les gens qui sont mécontents des
décisions prises par les responsables
non seulement les décisions politiques
mais aussi dans le domaine de la culture
et d'autres domaines oui oksana qu'est
ce que je peux vous dire à propos de
sergei faudra donc il représente un
parti qu'on connaît bien le parti l'a
soutenu et continuent à le soutenir
moi j'avais de bonnes relations avec lui
on peut caractériser de façon générale
comme un homme loyal vis-à-vis des
autorités centrales j'avais pas de
problème particulier avec lui
à mon avis je ne connais pas les
impressions de 39 et autant que je sache
il travaillait de façon tout à fait
corps et il travaillait de façon
appliquée en tant que gouverneur de la
région
mais les accusations qui sont portées
contre lui sont très graves
un membre de groupes criminels qui
aurait participé à la liquidation de
concurrents sur le plan commercial
il s'agit de crimes de meurtre
pas de vols pas de
deux bagarres d'abus de pouvoir il
s'agit de meurtres
donc vous comprenez que c'est une
accusation qui ira vous me demandez s'il
ya des informations supplémentaires qui
sont parvenus d'oncle enquête se
poursuit j'ai pas un lien tous les jours
avec eux pour savoir mais je comprends
les gens qui s'ils ont été déçus par les
informations sur fête qu'ils avaient été
interdits sous le coup d'une accusation
serré parce que c'est des gens qui
comptaient sur son travail son travail
qui le menait mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
il dézingue des accusations il n'y a pas
de poursuites politiques ici c'est une
question qui relève du pénal
et quand il s'agit de représentants
d'autres partis c'est la même chose des
représentants de du parti russie unie
on sait qu'il ya des représentants au
niveau régional du parti qui ont été
condamnés au cours de procès certains
effectuent une purge des peines
actuellement donc lescure à des
exclusions pour certains partis de nom
et de l'ensemble du spectre
des partis politiques malheureusement
nous sommes confrontés à ce phénomène et
le système judiciaire dans le pays doit
à s'abstraire de toute considération
politique et appliquer la loi de la même
façon les gares de tous maintenant je
donne la parole à novossibirsk
oui si le journal écrit déjà parce que
pendant la conférence
nous avons même dessiner de nouveaux
panneaux mais il ya ceux qui n'ont pas
de panneaux et et il ya un journaliste
qui n'a pas de panneau qui porte le
masque noir
elle n'a pas de panneau mais elle veut
poser une question bonjour
présentez-vous marescaux va vers de
terre car ils coûtent que la région un
d'irkoutsk il s'agit de l'écologie
monsieur poutine bonjour je suis à vous
poser la question suivante
ces dernières années il ya eu plusieurs
catastrophes écologiques plusieurs
incidents et vous optez finalement vous
avez dû prendre les mesures pour régler
ces problèmes
il s'agit de la situation de l'incident
à nos risques et oscille proches et
selon vous quelle peine mérite ils ceux
qui sont responsables
et est-ce que vous soutenez l'idée
d'augmenter les compétences et s'ils
voulaient bien voir
il faut quand même c'est un problème qui
doit être divisé en deux parties la
première concerne je vous prie de vous
asseoir tout d'abord il s'agit de
l'effet cumulé des dommages cumulé des
c'est l'activité des entreprises depuis
la période soviétique
et ce qui n'est pas lié à telle ou telle
entité publique non public c'est bien
sûr l'état est responsable des autorités
locales sont responsables oui c'est bien
sûr nous devons réagir à cela nous
contenu c'est comme krasny bord naulleau
pétersbourg ou souliers sibir ce qu'il y
ait d'autres s'étaient brouillés un
effet cumulatif le plus tôt aussi au cul
ce sera le mieux
il ya d'autres problèmes des programmes
à caractère cours qui sont exogènes dont
les responsables doivent être établies
par les organes de contrôle et qu'ils
devront prendre la décision sur le
niveau de responsabilité qui incombe
tout d'abord sous les poux sur les
pollueurs à namaro polders smam caire
responsabilités et doit être
proportionnée aux menaces réelles et au
niveau du des dommages
l'environnement et aux populations qui
vivent dans telle ou telle région
non ce qui aux heures c'est le cas
nordique elle je ne m'ingère pas je sais
que les exigences envers north nickel
sont très élevés oui derrière les rien à
dire vous devez bien être responsable
pour ce que vous avez fait et à nos
risques dans la ville de nourrice l'umam
la compagnie devrait s'intéresser
davantage à l'écologie aspect écologique
de son activité être plus attentifs
attentive à anvers les déchets et
peut-être services de santé qui
pourraient peut-être acheter une partie
des dépenses pour ses aspects de la vie
de cette région
maintenant je donne la parole à jean
smir agitation rouge qui n'a lagence
mire
monsieur poutine en 2000 en t1 le comité
de les états indépendants la célébrer
son anniversaire et a maintenant je
crois que le sehy impasse traverse une
crise
on voit au kurdistan et aussi les
manifestations en biélorussie et la
déclaration de maïs doux en moldavie qui
dit qu'il est nécessaire de faire partir
les forces de maintien de la paix de
moldavie est selon vous la russie ne
risque-t-elle de perdre ses partenaires
à ses amis vous avez dit nadejda que
c'est une crise d'un mur
en kirghizie ce serait pas la première
fois il ya toujours cette ce jeu de
chausse trappes a toujours ce désir
d'aller vite d'avoir pour s'organiser
selon certains pays occidentaux et plus
le niveau de conscience politique
le niveau de maturité des institutions
politiques dans ce pays n'est pas quand
même comme en france en france lui le
système politique ou en rfa 7 un système
politique qui s'est constituée qui a mis
des années des décennies peut-être même
des siècles les partis politiques la
pratique politique avec leur stabilité
de leur plateforme politique des choses
qui sont claires aux électeurs dans les
pays post soviétiques
tout cela tout cela peut se trouver ce
n'est pas le résultat des jeux leur
époque récente il faut respecter tous
nos partenaires
bien sûr la quête la quête de sa propre
voix de son identité
ce n'est pas il s'agit pas d'une
charnière tout simplement amaya sadouk
été élu à qui je souhaite tout le bien
ce qu'elle veut mais là comme un
représentant du certaines forces
politiques elles n'a dit rien de guinée
tillé ça fait longtemps que nous
entendons les représentants de
différents pays occidentaux de dire
qu'il faut retirer notre contingent de
paix de transnistrie et maïs doux ce
président m'avait citoyenne de roumanie
bon nous avons les pays occidentaux nous
disent qu'ils sont pour le retrait de
troupes de transnistrie quand la
situation sera adéquate
quand il y aura un dialogue normal entre
la transnistrie
elle le reste de la moldova quand il y
aura la paix quand on va nous sommes
pour nous étions proches avec le
président l'ancien président mais les
occidentaux ont fait pression sur lui
il a abandonné en fait il s'est retiré
des désaccords qu'on allait voir
et donc c'est est remise à plus tard et
puis j'ai posé deux avec les blessures
mais pourquoi quoi bon tout simplement
ça a été comme ça bon nous n'allons pas
analysé jusqu'aux pieds au menu détail
mais tôt ou tard ce problème doit être
résolu la baie de russie j'ai dit
plusieurs fois ce sujet il faut laisser
le peuple bélarusse à l'intérieur des
pays pauvres à y voir clair dans ces
situations il faudra régler calmement le
président loukachenko radisson avis à +0
plus je suis d'accord qu'il faut le
faire en toute sérénité
il a séduit main qui est initié des
modifications constitutionnelles
on va voir comment ça va se passer la
seule chose que nous voulions c'est sans
aucune ingérence externe parce que ce
que nous voyons aujourd'hui il y à une
ingérence informationnel politique
financière venant de l'étrange peut-être
de l'étranger parce que c'est qui vient
de l'étranger ça ne marche jamais vous
savez je vois parle vous si vous êtes en
train de sourire sert à une importance
de principe et pourquoi quelques dures
déficit ou là cela soit doit arriver à
maturité à l'intérieur d'un pays tout ce
qui est en quelque sorte endogènes et
exogènes pardon ça fonctionne comme une
grande aide comme un commissaire
explosive
il faut savoir avoir la patience et
attendre d'aider toutes les forces
politiques au lieu de se faire la guerre
de d'arriver à un dialogue positif
visant à défendre l'intérêt des citoyens
bien sûr il y aurait des vêtements
bientôt dans le cadre de la c8 et je
pense ce sera utile et au porteur avec
nos collègues d'évoquer nos priorités on
revient et que tu hambourg où chaque
collègue personnes accueillies ici parce
que
ce sont les sibériens mais on il ya
encore plus de panneaux les journalistes
ont un dessiner un cri de nouveaux
panneaux et même je tiens à donner la
parole à cette jeune fille a avec le
pnue et le mot qu'on a appris tôt cette
année
je m'appelle ekaterina bychkova j'ai
écrit le mot le look down ou confinement
qu'on utilise partout et voilà la
question suivante qu'on a envie roussat
a affecté l'ensemble de notre économie
ne l'avons pas reçu 10 milliards de
roubles qu'on a réduit recevoir notre
budget les petites et moyennes
entreprises et soufflent les grandes
entreprises aussi certaines entreprises
doivent l'essentiel remployer certaines
entreprises doivent employés licenciés à
l'ensemble de leurs employés bien sûr
que au niveau fédéral régional
on soutient les entreprises les gens
mais la situation demeure grave et
quelles sont les perspectives de sortie
de cette crise et comment la crise et la
deuxième question quand peut-on revenir
à la période normale il est tout à fait
des questions tout à fait légitimes à
cheikh catherine millet khatir une
boucle c'est l'oural
par ailleurs c'est un grand centre
industriel
de ta nationale dans tout ce qui est lié
aux restrictions liées par le la
pandémie quant à virale cela rejaillit
sur la région et l'économie dans son
ensemble
là je vais peut-être m'arrêter en des
m'attardais avait sur cette question
parce que c'est c'est essentiel pour le
pays qui sont les secteurs les plus les
plus exposés qui ont le plus souffert
tout d'abord les transports l'aviation
aux chemins de fer surtout les voyeurs
train de voyages transport de voyageurs
puis les détaillants d'articles non
alimentaires et la sphère de service cet
arrière
bien sûr tous les filtres sincère les
restaurants cafés on s'est dit que le
gouvernement s'est longuement penché sur
cette question pendant toute cette année
avec l'administration présidentielle
donc des décisions ont été prises pour
soutenir les citoyens aient l'économie
dans son ensemble
il faut dire je viens du site et des
secteurs ce qui a été fait dans ce
secteur tout d'abord nous nous avons
restructuré paiement surtout pour la tva
deuxièmement nous avons reporté eu des
allocations accordées
troisièmement il ait eu des créances 0-2
1-0
quatrièmement un crédit à taux d'intérêt
de 2 pour ça avec la compensation de
l'annulation de tout le crédit si avec
une réduction des personnels qui porte à
50 % de créer des annulations
s'il gardait la has 80 pour sao du
personnel nous avons reporté à plus tard
les versements pour location des biens
publics et pour les pme nous avons
décidé de réduire les cotisations
sociales de 33 à 15 pour ça et ça pour
ce jour pas seulement le temps de la
pandémie
cette fois ce temps une série de mesures
qui dans leur ensemble ont soutenu
l'économie
ce qu'ils étaient
l'économie en souffrance en outre nous
avons aussi travaillé avec le secteur
formant système l'industrie automobile
construction aéronautique construction
navale la vie culture et le bâtiment
pour notre mobile de tous les programmes
continuent à se développer vous l'avez
eue hier un best fait un avec notre
moteur moteur 14
c'est pratiquement prototype à
industriels c'est une grande réalisation
pour nos constructeurs de moteurs et
pour les constructions aéronautiques
ces puits il 114 qui a fait un vol
l'appareil
l'aéronef complètement neuf nous
complètement nous les constructions dans
le civil qui es tu
qui a pourtant dépit de tout le bâtiment
dans cette année va construire un peu
moi mais dans ce dans l'ensemble nous
avons soutenu le secteur
donc les habitats et le secteur lui-même
y compris grâce à aux crédits mobiliers
de 6,2 pour cent d'intérêt c'était comme
une aide sérieuse pour l'économie et
dans l'ensemble nous avons affecté os ou
10 euros ce tiers des citoyens de
l'industrie et de lutte contre la
pandémie 4,6 millions de roubles et
qu'est ce qui est sans précédent pour
nous c'est 4,4 pour cent du pib du pays
donc la moitié c'est pour se découvrir
le 38 milliards dhs pour soutenir
directement les habitants souhaitent une
série de mesures qui a été élaboré il a
fallu aidé à concevoir salle initié le
mettre en forme tous ces mesures donc
tout cela a été utilisé efficacement
nous pensons aussi nous nous
interrogeons sur l'avenir bien sûr la
sortie de la crise la sortie de la crise
elle dépendra de notre manière de
maîtriser la pandémie quand est ce que
nous allons passer à une vaccination or
de masse si nous sommes capables de
lever toutes les restrictions qui sont
encore en vigueur et je pense que
dans les six mois qui viennent la
situation va vieillir à en mieux et pour
l'économie
donc selon diverses estimations vers la
fin 2011 à 20 ans
à l'horizon en première moitié de 2022
nous allons surmonter tous ces problèmes
à mam l'année prochaine il y aura de
nouvelles tendances positives pour le
pib du pays
tout le monde devra travailler
activement tout le monde a besoin de
travailler et m'ont pas de départ ce que
nos objectifs nos hôtes étaient imposés
donc il nous faudra les atteindre on
revient au centre d'appel ne vous entend
pas pourriez vous répéter votre question
dans les conditions difficiles
l'attendent émis ses allocutions sont
très importantes et la question est ce
qu'il y aura de nouvelles allocations en
est ce que vous pourriez reprendre votre
question depuis le début nous avons
réussi une question d'analyser tout
retard aux vagues qui n'a pas ri sud
allocution à novembre et décembre pour
son bébé qui a neuf mois elle ne sait
pas où aller dans ces conditions
compliquées c'est le seul soutien le
seul moyen pour elles est ce qu'il y
aura de nouvelles allocution regardez
j'ai déjà répondu à une question
similaire à propos des allocations nous
effectuons un suivi permanent de la
situation et nous réfléchissons à de
nouvelles allocations qu'ils puissent
être mis en place si en novembre
décembre la femme n'a pas reçu les
allocations prévues ça veut dire que le
système lui-même fonctionne mal
il ya eu des problèmes c'est à dire dont
ceux celles que nous avons mis en place
donc il faut commencer par voir ici
réparer les défaillances remettre en
place ce système
donc que cette personne qui a adressé
cette demande nous fasse suivre ça ça
demande son adresse son nom c est que le
système du guichet unique fonctionne
normalement et ça nous allons suivre
sait quelle raison encore une fois
quelle région encore une fois la région
pajr acheter d'accord je comprends donc
je pense que les responsables régionaux
nous entendent concrètement séquelles
ville nous allons mettre une minute vous
trouvez cette demande puisque il faut
qu'on sache
concrètement ce s'est convaincu que en
bachkirie ou le responsable régional est
assez jeune et dynamique
on devrait pouvoir identifier cette
défaillance dans quelle localité ça
s'est produit
d'accord on va trouver à et maintenant
novo ogaryovo les journalistes elle
coule du kremlin je vois erté rachou des
oui c'est ça igor jdanov rachat today
monsieur poutine j'ai une question sur
la sécurité notamment sur la menace
terroriste la russie a toujours accusé
tout attentat terroriste est la russie
continue de les condamner et critiquée
en europe ces données on voit qu'il ya
des attentes à croquer par les
caricatures
sur le prophète mais la russie ne
soutient pas la publication de ces
caricatures mais où est la frontière
entre la liberté d'expression qui est le
droit fondamental de chacun et en ce qui
concerne la russie qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour prévenir ce scénario européen
là où où est cette limite je vais rien
vous dire de nouveau c'est à dire que
l'année m entre une liberté et cette
autre débat donc je me prends bien ces
deux là où commence la liberté de
l'autre
finie la vôtre donc il faut bien
comprendre ce principe général est ce
qui offense la fois les sentiments des
croyants doivent toujours garder à
l'esprit que il y aura une réaction
mais d'un autre côté cette réaction elle
doit pas être agressive et à propos de
toutes les religions mondiales qu'ils
s'agissent de du christianisme de
l'islam dans la bible dans le coran ou
chez les bouddhistes aussi toutes les
grandes religions mondiales le disent
y'a pas d'allusion à l'agression la
défense de ces droits ne justifie pas de
ta part
une réaction agressive et supprimer la
vie de l'autre donc cet esprit de
vengeance et est extérieur à toutes ces
grandes religions laisse le seigneur
donne la vie le seigneur la reprend et
et quelle est notre attitude en russie
et qu'est ce que nous faisons pour
éviter une telle situation vous
comprenez bien que la russie dans son
origine est un état pluriconfessionnelle
donc il ya une culture de relations
entre les représentants des différentes
religions et c'est un héritage très
important que ce qui nous a été remis
par les générations précédentes
il ya eu beaucoup de cas de pages
sombres dans notre histoire
par exemple la déportation d'une de
certains peuples
après la seconde guerre mondiale où on
n'en parle pas beaucoup mais enfin c'est
quand même ça figure dans notre histoire
je vais pas donner d'appréciation sur ce
qui s'est passé mais les représentants
de ces peuples qui ont été victimes de
répression ils ont accueilli
et ils ont accueilli par tous ceux qui
les ont libérés de ces iem de ce qui
venait à envahir leurs terres
donc il ya eu des traîtres par tous mais
après il ya d'autres personnes qui se
sont battues jusqu'au bout pour défendre
la russie et notamment de ses
représentants qui ont été victimes de
répressions pourquoi je dis tout ça ce
que je retiens pas eu il ya pas eu de
répression pour des raisons hors jo oui
le pour le pouvoir soviétique a
poursuivi à persécuter des prêtres mais
c'étaient des prêtres de toutes les
religions donc ça c'est important il n'y
a pas eu de persécution proprement
religieuse c'est à dire que la culture
de respect entre les représentants des
différentes religions et aussi du côté d
art et donc c'est une tradition qui
s'est mise en place au cours des siècles
et grâce à dieu personne n'admet qu'on
puisse porter de telles insultes de
telle offense et je vous demande à tous
de faire en sorte que cela n'arrive
jamais et que à l'intérieur de notre
pays nous puissions garder cette entente
alors ce qui se produit dans certains
pays européens il faut comprendre que au
fond qu'est ce qui se passe dans
certains pays européens par des
représentants de l'islam représentent
10% de la population et ce sont des
immigrés soit de la première de la
deuxième
génération alors que nous se sont pas
des immigrés ce sont des gens de notre
pays vivent dans leurs troupeaux mieux
donc
donc c'est une différence fondamentale
ici pour comprendre la façon dont ces
relations entre les confessions se
construisent dans notre pays et dans
d'autres pays
le multikulti
[Musique]
culturelle ne s'est pas réalisé ça a été
un fiasco complet on a vu il faut il
faut le reconnaître que ça ce projet n'a
pas marché mais chez nous nous il s'est
mis en place au cours des siècles tout
seul et ça c'est très précieux pour nous
j'ai une question concernant l'agenda
international concernant le conflit dans
le haut karabakh et j'ai divisé ma
question en toi en question la première
question pourquoi ce conflit s'est
aggravé jeu juste maintenant est ce
qu'il y a des explications ou est ce que
quelqu'un a incité ce conflit de
l'étranger la deuxième question à la
réaction de la turquie
on sait bien que un quart a soutenu
bakou pendant la période la plus aiguë
de ce conflit et puis la turquie a
participé à ce centre de surveillance
donc bien évidemment la turquie a ses
propres intérêts dans cette région mais
quels sont les intérêts de la russie
dans cette région est est ce qu'il ya
une certaine correspondance des intérêts
entre la russie et la turquie et la
troisième partie de ma question c'est la
situation dans la région de ghat doute
selon vous est ce que il ya un risque
élevé que il y aura de nouvelles
violations du cessez le feu et qu'est ce
que la russie va faire dans le cadre de
violations par et est ce que on peut
augmenter le nombre de notre
militaire notre contingent de maintien
de la paix et on voit que dans ses pieds
là les tensions ceux provoqués par la
différence dans l'attitude des partis à
l'égard du 4e paragraphe de l'accord
selon laquelle le contingent russe est
déployée en parallèle avec le départ des
forces armées donc les forces armées
arméniennes doivent quitter le haut
karabagh et c'est ce que croit bakou et
erevan estiment qu'ils doivent quitter
uniquement les territoires qui sont
cédés donc les arméniens estiment qu'ils
doivent quitter uniquement les
territoires qu'ils cèdent en vertu de
cet accord et les azéris crois que les
forces arméniennes doivent complètement
doivent être retirés du haut karabakh
donc j'ai une question à cet égard voix
en tant que l'un des auteurs de cet
accord trilatéral pourriez vous préciser
vous alliez vous pashinian qu'est ce que
vous voulez dire par cela
vous avez posé une question très longue
et cette discussion pour être poursuivi
toute la nuit pourquoi cela tout s'est
il produit
maintenant la question
le contrôle a été de lacq estimation a
été perdu
la tension n'a cessé de se maintenir
pendant de longues années et je pense
pas que ce soit intervenue en raison
d'une
actions venues de l'extérieur à
plusieurs reprises nous avons vu des
échanges de tirs
des conflits très locaux sur le plan et
tout cela a dégénéré dans un conflit
généralisé la russie partait de la
position que il faut éviter toute
effusion de sang telles que ç'avait été
formulée déjà dans les négociations de
minsk avec les états unis et la france
pendant de longues années je répète
notre position pour sauter c'est à dire
que c'est que cette territoires doivent
tête autour du nagorny karabakh doit
être restitué à l'azerbaïdjan le statut
du haut karabakh doit rester inchangés
c'est à dire que à l'avenir le statu quo
doit être entérinée officiellement avec
la mise en place de des changes entre le
haut karabakh et la ramener
et pour cela il était prévu de mettre en
place le corridor de latchine c'est à
dire entre l'arménie et le cabba
pourquoi la chine parce que la chine
c'est la localité justement qui est
située
alors à l'emplacement de ce corps dans
la position de la turquie c'est elle que
cette position qui a été publiquement
présenté et qui est celle de la région
c'est la restitution des territoires
occupés au cours des conflits des
combats dans les années 90 à
l'azerbaïdjan du point de vue du droit
international tous ces territoires font
partie intégrante de la république d
azerbaïdjan
je le répète encore une fois
l'arménie ne reconnaissait pas
l'indépendance du haut-karabakh et
compte tenu de cette situation
le statut du haut karabagh théoriquement
selon droite un simple faisait partie du
de l'argent en réalité la situation est
plus complexe que ses dénonciations
juridique du direct
ici on a un conflit ethnique qui est un
peu preuve qu'ils qui a évolué d'antan
et chaque partie finalement a ses
propres raisons et les arméniens du
haut-karabakh avaient pris les armes
pour défendre leur vie et leur biens et
la situation telle qu'elle était au
moment où cette année
la crise a dégénéré fait que nous sommes
mis d'accord dans le cadre de cet accord
tripartite pour un cessation des combats
et ça c'est important nous sommes mis
d'accord sur le fait que les parties
s'arrête là où elle était à la date de
la signature de l'accord tripartite et
par conséquent il y a un certain nombre
d'aspects techniques qui se pose ici qui
sont liées aux infrastructures d'accord
d'ailleurs cet accord est très important
et je les ai déjà dit ce qui est
important c'est que l'effusion de sang à
cesser les gens ont cessé de moon et ça
c'est important c'est primordial le
reste est secondaire
la vie et la santé des gens c'est
prioritaire préserver la vie des gens
c'est ça l'objectif premier
ce que je veux dire c'est que les forces
armées se sont arrêtés là où elle était
au moment de la signature de l'accord
après il ya des questions techniques qui
se posent autant pour les arméniens que
pour les arbres et john
il faut juger de ces questions de façon
des cibles apaisé dans le cadre de
négociations
aujourd'hui on a tous les éléments pour
trouver il se léchant il a été écrit que
après le cessez le feu il faut une
normalisation complète une amazone avec
la mise en valeur de tout potentiel
économique social au niveau des
transports aussi des transports
automobiles par exemple ça correspond si
la région d'une richie chevannes sacré
c'est dans l'intérêt de l'arménie aussi
il ya eu une seule violation du
cessez-le-feu j'espère que ce n'est
qu'un cas unique qui restera comme tel
mais il faut que tout le monde se
mettent à la table des négociations et
qu'on discute
il ya le il ya le processus de minsk oui
mais ce qu'il faut c'est que ces
discussions se poursuivent
allez je vous a répondu sur la question
de la position des troupes ce que nous
voulons c'est que mais bien évidemment
les médiateurs internationaux puissent
aider les gens qui ont besoin des deux
pour que les réfugiés puissent revenir
dans leur lieu d'habitation dans le
haut-karabakh donc pas seulement la
russie apporte sa contribution en
mettant un contingent de la paix mais il
ya aussi l'unicef et d'autres
organisations internationales et
d'autres organisations de des deux côtés
qui puisse apporter leur aide et nous de
notre côté nous sommes prêts à
poursuivre nos travaux en ce qui
concerne le contingent de la paix
l'effectif peut-être augmenter mais
seulement sur la base d'un accord avec
les deux parties et notamment avec les
abidjanais puisque nous avions annoncé
un effectif précis c'est un effectif qui
a été validé dans le cadre de l'accord
avec l'ensemble des parties et qui est
adapté c'est une question d'ordre
purement technique si les autres
considèrent que cet effectif doit être
modifiée nous sommes
nous y sommes prêts mais la question ce
n'est pas seulement le contingent de la
paix c'est le fonctionnement de nos
services du ministère des situations
d'urgence des des services de douanes du
fsb et ses grottes et voilà pour cette
conférence annuelle de vladimir poutine
déjà plus de trois heures de questions
réponses avec les journalistes une
conférence qui se poursuit et à suivre
en intégralité sur notre site internet
rt france point tv on va retrouver tout
de suite antoine cléroux notre
correspondant à moscou fin antoine alors
que retenir de cette conférence de
presse qui se poursuit je le précise
encore oui déjà plus de trois heures de
conférence de presse se sont écoulés et
de très nombreux de très nombreux sujets
ont déjà été évoqués avec en premier
lieu la crise sanitaire bien sûr et ses
conséquences sur la vie quotidienne des
citoyens russes
mais il aussi répondu à de très
nombreuses questions sur des questions
relatives à l'actualité internationale
va dire poutine ainsi abordés on viens
de l'entendre la problématique du haut
karabakh mais aussi le conflit dans le
donbass il a dit regretter le manque
d'avancées concrètes de la part des
autorités ukrainiennes qui d'après lui
craignent les forces nationalistes du
pays
ces mêmes autorités ukrainiennes qui
toujours d'après vladimir poutine ne
respecte pas les accords de minsk sans
qui sont ces accords il ne peut y avoir
de règlement politique à ce conflit il
ensuite évoqué la sphère navalni sans
jamais citer le nom de l'opposant russe
et les dernières accusations qui
impliquerait d'après certains d'après
certains médias occidentaux qui
impliquerait la participation d'agents
du fsb écoutez sa réponse
je dirais que ce patient de la clinique
bernoise
il bénéficie de l'appui des services
secrets américains concrètement alors
synthes en droit ça veut dire
qu'effectivement les services secrets
doivent suivre cette affaire de près
vous comprenez alors l'enquêté peut-être
et peut-être pas achevé il faut la
poursuivre et le cieux son épouse a
demandé à pouvoir le suivre en allemagne
j'ai donné l'autorisation et politique
international avec qui ils préfèrent
s'entretenir va dire poutine a donné
deux noms celui du président chinois xi
jinping avec qui il dit entretenir une
relation d'amitié mais aussi le
président turc recep tayyip erdogan chez
qui il dit apprécier son franc parler
dans une certaine mesure sa
prévisibilité ainsi malgré leurs
tensions et parfois leurs différences
très accentué il arrive à avancer à
s'entendre sur des sujets parfois très
compliqué alors comme je le disais au
début leurs questions les questions les
plus nombreuses l'ont été à propos de
cette pandémie de qu'ovide 19 il a
défendu la dir kutina défendu le système
de santé russes qui a su s'adapter
d'après lui et a également évoqué le cas
des vaccins russe on lui a même posé
cette question monsieur le président
comptez vous vous faire vacciner je vous
propose d'écouter sa réponse les vaccins
qui sont en circulation
la population sont destinés à une
certaine catégorie d'âge et pour
l'instant les gens comme moi ne sont pas
encore concernés par cette catégorie
je mets
respecte la loi je suis les
recommandations de nos spécialistes est
pour l'instant moi je me suis fais pas
je me suis pas fait vacciner mais je le
ferai dès que ce sera possible
et voilà pour cette intervention donc
dans son numéro notre correspondant on a
décrypté avec lui cette conférence de
presse de vladimir poutine qui se
poursuit est à suivre en direct sur
notre site arte france au point tv on en
parle tout de suite également avec
eugène berg il est ancien diplomate
spécialiste de la russie
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france on le voit que
chaque année pour le président russe est
un rendez vous très important pour
quelles raisons selon vous bah écoutez
c'est important à la fois parce que ça
lui permet de rester évidemment en
contact avec la nation et et cette année
en particulier parce que le ça est
évidemment une année très difficile à
cause de la pandémie
et puis ça a été l'année de toutes les
réformes dans la discussion donc
monsieur poutine ne pouvait pas ne pas
manquer cette occasion auxquels ils
tirer beaucoup 1 depuis très longtemps
et donc cette année encore particulier
d'autant plus que contre nous il ya
malheureusement à auch il ya des petits
bruits sur sa santé sur son état donc
des rumeurs bon surtout dans une
certaine presse occidentale ou qu'elle
évidemment une prête pas attention parce
que ça fait un petit peu aisée trop de
la rue la plus basse donc voilà je crois
que ces essais s'étaient partiellement
important pour rassurer et comme je
l'entends durant rues jusqu'à présent ça
commence évidemment toutes les questions
qui ont été posées tourner autour
duco vide évidemment de la vaccination
est ce que d y aura suffisamment de
vaccins de la pauvreté il ya des
chiffres qui l'a rassuré de l'est le
gouvernement par la gousse et aux
secteurs qui sont les plus impactées en
quelque sorte tout ce qui est transport
aérien l'agriculture la construction il
ya eu d'autres questions de politique
étrangère
on y reviendra peut-être évidemment donc
voila un petit peu et j'ai trouvé un
président calme
habillée dans un costume bleu cravate
bleue alors que son conseiller de
précieux et cravate rouge donc tout ça
est fait le bien organisés comme
toujours bien huilée chaque chaque
région on voit défiler dans des tentes
dans des locaux beaucoup de journalistes
qui posent des questions et s'est
transmis comme ça d'une dune d'un an de
tout les coins de la russie le présent
poutine prend des notes
écoute attentivement des questions qui
sont parfois un petit peu aiguë donc je
crois que c'est un exercice qui est
qu'il n'est pas usé et quoi malgré les
longues d'année au calysto poursuit qui
intéressent l'opinion publique les
journalistes et qui me semble être
écoutés à la fois en russie et à
l'extérieur voilà un peu le l'impression
la première impression qu'on peut tirer
de déjà de ces trois heures
oui c'est ça alors vous le disais il ya
bien sûr une ni deux il ya beaucoup
d'inventions
il ya beaucoup plus de trois heures et
il ya beaucoup de d'information vous le
disais qu'il remonte du terrain vous
pensez que ça lui sert à vladimir
poutine dans sa gouvernance
comment ça il ya beaucoup d'informations
qui remonte du terrain vous le disiez
vous même
est ce que ça lui sert à vladimir
poutine dans sa gouvernance
oui oui ça lui sert bon d'abord tout
homme politique surtout montre qu'il
s'intéresse aux jo et je crois qu'ils
écoutent il écoute il prend des notes et
ensuite ça lui permet de relancer les
gouverneurs qui doivent évidemment
écouté les doléances beau parfois
certains journalistes prennent la
liberté critique est leur gouverneur de
montrer qu'il ya certains manquements et
donc c'est une manière je veux dire de
démocratie directe qui permet ensuite au
président poutine vladimir poutine de
relancer soit blâmé soin de rappeler à
l'ordre
mais surtout de faire avancer les choses
alors évidemment il peut pas il peut pas
intervenir sur 15700 un problème à la
fois mais il en prend les plus
importants qui se recoupent par exemple
il ya une personne ont pas parlé que de
haute politique de santé vous savez
certainement que les problèmes des
ordures était délicat il s'est créé des
gens des 12-19 puisqu'il n'y avait pas
de d'endroit pour incinération trop de
trucs et les verdures des ordures et 2
des camions partent est de moscou et les
déposaient donc une personne n'a posé
par la cdu questions importantes faut
pas l'oublier est ce que c'est une
question qui a été a été repoussé les
dits non pas du tout on y veille
évidemment maintenant on a moins de
ressources mais où keller aucun grand
objectif national qui devait commencer à
mettre en oeuvre à partir de pas de
cette année de janvier quoi ils ont pris
six mois de retard mais aucun n'a été
commise et donc et les projets nationaux
certains par exemple correspondre à une
une réponse à la pandémie par exemple il
a parlé de 39 milles ou quarante mille
écoles et bien en 21 il a dit il faut
absolument les branchés sur
l'informatique l'internet parce que la
sambre de cours pour devront est
poursuivi
voilà donc l'équipement de tout le
secteur universitaire et scolaire doigté
trash et qui est loin d'être le cas
maintenant et beaucoup d'écoles ont dû
certainement fermés travailler en sous
régime réduit évidemment souffrir de la
situation le président russe qui a aussi
fait un point sur la situation
économique de son pays selon lui la
russie s'en sort mieux que certains pays
c'est vrai selon vous balala j'ai pas bu
bon là j'ai pas entendu ça il a plutôt
parlé de l'aide de l'inflation bon le
d'après bon inscrit la russie s'en sort
oui s'en sort mais tout mieux que la
france a la une baisse de pipe de 7 à 8%
alors que nous on va on va être autour
de 9 pour l'allemagne t5 et demie enfin
on va pas leur entrée dans des
situations du tableau d'honneur ou pas
alors trois chiffres que j'ai retenu
qu'il paraisse qu'on est important et
qui ne vous presque étonné quand lui est
arrivé au pouvoir le taux de pauvreté
est à 29 % de la population en 2017 12,3
est aujourd'hui très et demi alors que
beaucoup de gens pensaient que c'était
sa dépasser 15 donc voilà le chief qu'il
a donné il faut regarder et il dit que
le mon objectif c'est de les réduire de
moitié à six et demi donc voilà un
chiffre important
le deuxième c'est l'inflation elle est
autour de 4 4,1 donc là aussi elle n'a
pas augmenté parce que je vends
problèmes de rareté
on pourrait croire que les prix
augmentent surtout quand les frais de
distribution sont gonflés et le
troisième c'est intéressant c'est le
paquet dead qu'on appelle qui il a
évalué à 4,5 pour cent du pib' alors
c'est moins que certains pays comme le
japon 10 % chez nous mais attention sans
rentrer dans un débat de spécialistes
quand parle hacker dead il ya les
crédits il ya les garanties c'est pas de
l'argent frais qui arrive pour soutenir
des entreprises qui ont dû fermer leurs
portes
tant qu'il a il a montré les différentes
a donc quatre et demi c'est global il
est difficile de comparer
chaque pays a son propre programme et le
manque nature sont pas toujours les
mêmes quoi pour pour finir alors nous ne
savons pas si vladimir poutine a été
mise au courant de cette information on
l'a appris ce matin emmanuel macron été
testé positif aux qu'ovide 19 votre
réaction par rapport à cela et surtout
est-ce que ça peut avoir un impact sur
la gestion de la crise sanitaire en
france mais au niveau repeint aussi
parce qu'on a appris aussi que charles
michel allait être mise en quarantaine
le président du conseil européen et la
rencontre emmanuel macron lundi et puis
aussi le premier ministre portugais
aussi qui est à l' isolement
ouais bah écoutez ma première réaction
c'est on est désolé parce que le
président bak rond comme vous c'est
celui-ci je reprends leur russe
voulait malgré toutes les critiques
malgré la sphère de bailly malgré tout
et il le persistait à établir un
dialogue avec la russie est un franc
dialogue ouvert donc ce dialogue
certainement va leur prendre du retard
et en ce qui concerne l'europe
effectivement au moment où byden arrive
vous monsieur tron va partir
l'europe fait mauvaise figure quoi à la
fois économiquement des habits d'une
chine qualifiée triomphante sans aucune
ironie la chine s'en est sorti c'est pas
débat actuel économiquement et une
manières sanitaires d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce que si on encore une
seconde je m'échappe pas quelqu'un dit
adam né après la guerre petit quels sont
les interlocuteurs vous avez aimé dur et
où il répond d'une manière très
diplomatique
moi je dialogue avec tout le monde je
classe pas les bons et les méchants
tout le monde cherche à son intérêt mais
vous n'avez pas nommer la chine et voyez
moi j'ai des relations d'amitié les
cuisines pin serrar voilà donc
s'intéressant qu'aux et il a un corps
tenu à montrer alors bon on verra ce qui
se passera le tai ji
mais en ce qui concerne l'europe l'ours
puisqu'on arts à une redistribution sur
le chaîne mondiale internationale on a
une chine puissante si monde on a une
amérique est ce que va revenir ou pas
prudente c'est beaucoup de choses
une réussite il finalement sans arrêt
tellement bien
qui est fable ordonné qu'ils essayent de
régler ses problèmes avec 6 dans ce pays
alors que l'europe
le quatrième pilier de l'ordre mondial
je ne dirais pas qui s'écroule mais il
est un peu faiblard et est normalement
dans un monde multipolaire qui est
d'ailleurs qu'il veut de la russie si
l'europe est absente
ça manque ça manquait tournure quand
même citoyen européen qui voulons une
grande sécurité dans le cadre
paneuropéen jeu pas encore d'un petit
canal
si nous nous sommes sur les moins
présents - qui fait est un peu handicapé
par seprem de santé qu'on n'a pas pu
régler les premiers économique et sont
liés c'est vraiment dommage
dans l'eure a perdu des mois précieux
juste pour conclure on va se rendre du
côté de l'elysée dans un instant pour
faire le point sans l'information qu'on
évoquait emmanuel macron positif aux
copines mais sur les relations russo
américaines et il y a fait allusion
vladimir poutine
il a semblé tendre une perche à radio
maidan non non bon vous savez sur toile
et je lui
j'écoute toutes les questions et repas
non il a simplement dit bon c'est qu'il
a il ay là on dira il a félicité ses
tardivement élevé trois jours quoi il a
attendu que finalement que la le site
officiel pour sembler un peu juridique
quoi on peut importe voit pas close et
là dessus non simplement il a dit
j'espère que monsieur bei den qu'on va
établir des relations ouvertes
coopérative et voilà mais ça s'est jadis
et normalien s'éduque comme un tocard
yens nouveaux cas autant il a été
chaleureux avec son ami si j'ai le pin
avec bailan il reste prudent parce que
il d'ailleurs c'est marrant on va pas
vendre la peau de l'ours
surtout levé avant de l'avoir tué sans
aucune ironie
donc il faut voir finalement on attend
alors tout le monde sait qu en dehors de
ça le gros problème c'est les soldes 2cv
curie pour les problèmes le reste est le
salt de 10 ce qui a été établi entre
obama et medvedev en 2009 où l'air les
missiles devrait être qu'un sens les
porter par les danseurs
eh bien ils vont expirer en deux ans en
février prochain c'est à dire demain et
si
il sait pas encore n'est pas reconduit
tous les accords et je suis ça depuis
des décennies tous les accords et les
fêtes vont disparaître donc tout larmes
ce contrôle tous les sites web tout le
dialogue entre russie et états unis va
disparaître c'est énorme
merci beaucoup à vous un gène berg
d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions d'avoir commenté avec mon
cette conférence de presse je rappelle
que vous êtes ancien ambassadeur à
spécialiste de la russie une conférence
de presse donc qui se poursuit à suivre
en direct sur notre site rtl france
point tv on en vient donc à cette
information de la matinée manuel macron
qui a été testé positif aux colis 19
qu'il va s'isoler pendant sept jours
c'est ce qu'a annoncé l'élysée de même
que le premier ministre jean castex ta
contact du président on retrouve tout de
suite devant l'elysée quatre cpcq nique
pour faire le point et katia à bonjour
alors quelles sont les dernières
informations sur la santé du président
écoutez emmanuel macron présenté des
symptômes légers
il a fait un test pcr qui revenu positif
aujourd'hui je vous propose d'écouter le
communiqué de presse de l'elysée à son
sujet le président de la république a
été diagnostiqué positif à la coved 19
ce jour ce diagnostic a été établi suite
à un test
rt pcr réalisé dès l'apparition des
premiers symptômes
conformément aux consignes sanitaires en
vigueur applicables à tous
le président de la république s'isolera
pendant sept jours il continuera de
travailler et d'assurer ses activités à
distance donc mis à l'isolément emmanuel
macron continuera à travailler mais il
devra évidemment annulé ce déplacement
donc son voyage au liban la semaine
prochaine sera annulé quant à jean
castex le premier ministre ils ne
présentent pas de symptômes pour le
moment il sera testé pressèrent réseau
puis il devra annuler la présentation de
sa stratégie vaccinale au sénat c'est
olivier verront ministre de la santé qui
va s'en charger donc il est mis à
l'isolément à l'isolément également
richard ferrand le président de
l'assemblée nationale jugé qu'à
contacter alors parlons un peu des
occasions de contamination mardi midi
les neuf présidents des groupes
parlementaires de l'assemblée nationale
ont été reçus à déjeuner à l'elysée il y
avait christophe castaner le patron et
les roms à l'assemblée damien battre
pour les républicains valérie rabault
pour le ps jean luc mélenchon pour la
france insoumise pour ne citer qu'eux
mais ne sont pas considérés comme cas
contacts car il aurait respecté les
mesures barrières les gestes qu'il
convient de déployer dans ce cas autre
événement qui fait jaser en revanche la
fête hier soir qui a été donné dans la
salle des fêtes de l'elysée selon une
information du point alors il aurait
rassemblé des dirigeants de la majorité
des directeurs de cabinet étaient
présents le premier ministre jean castex
il y avait richard ferrand christophe
castaner françois bayrou encore patrick
mignola le président du modem
alors pour les participants interrogé
par le point les règles de distanciation
sociales ont été respectées les gestes
barrière également mais disons que ce
type de rassemblement une dizaine de
personnes qui s'est terminée
vers minuit et demi donc tu n'as pas
vraiment respecté les consignes les
consignes de nombreux qui ont été
données par le gouvernement est bien ne
montre pas vraiment l'exemple
si beaucoup avouent katia technique pour
toutes ces précisions vous l'avez dit
jean castex qui n'ont que n'a pas
présenté la stratégie vaccinale devant
le sénat ce matin mais olivier ferrand
le ministre de la santé oui objectif
exposer la stratégie du gouvernement un
plan en trois étapes définir aussi les
publics prioritaires
on rappelle hier à l'assemblée nationale
le premier ministre a annoncé que les
premières vaccinations devait débuter
dès la dernière semaine de décembre pour
les populations prioritaires on retrouve
sur place notre reporter ben hassen
chébili devant le sénat bassem à bonjour
jour d'explication dont je les dis pour
le gouvernement sur la stratégie
vaccinale sans jean castex et on l'a dit
dans un contexte particulier puisque
emmanuel macron et est positif aux
copies de disques effectivement samantha
c'était le même exercice
aujourd'hui pour le gouvernement que je
suis qui a été fait hier à l'assemblée
nationale et devant les députés à la
seule différence qui r c'est le premier
ministre jean castex qui a commencé de
locutions alors qu'aujourd'hui à lille
et veyran le mr santé était seul le vrai
ministre gk contact suite bien sûr la
contamination au qu'ovide 19 et emmanuel
macron mais l'exercice a été fait devant
les sénateurs
une déclaration suivie d'un débat qui
aura duré à peu près deux heures les
mines sur la santé a clôturé bien sûr
ces débats il est revenu aujourd'hui
comme hier devant les sénateurs pour
expliquer les fondements et les
modalités de cette stratégie vaccinale
du gouvernement il est revenu sur les
vaccins dans un premier temps en disant
qu'ils allaient être livrés
simultanément simultanément comme le
reste des pays européens et bien sûr au
même prix que nos voisins européens en
tout ce sont 200 millions de doses qui
ont été commandés pour la france pour
100 millions de patients de laboratoire
ont été choisis par l'ensemble des
partenaires européens à savoir
laboratoire moderna et le laboratoire
pfizer le ministre la santé a déclaré
que la priorité dans un premier temps
c'était bien sûr d'identifier les
patients au prioritaires à savoir les
personnes âgées surtout les personnes
dans les ehpad pour cette première phase
de vaccination comme vous l'avez dit
qu'il sera prévue à partir de la fin de
décembre je vous propose d'écouter aux
différents
ministre de la santé j'avais ensuite la
deuxième étape de la vaccination tout
cela va dépendre évidemment du rythme de
livraison des différents vaccins et en
fonction des arrivées des doses de
vaccin ne nous élargirons
progressivement le public pouvant
bénéficier en priorité de la vaccination
ce sera en ville que les choses se
passeront en lien direct avec les
médecins traitants avec les soignants
avec l'appui fondamentale des
pharmaciens cela concernera les
personnes âgées de 75 ans et plus cela
concernera également les personnes dans
un deuxième temps de 65 ans et plus et
ensuite les professionnels de santé du
secteur sanitaire et médico-social âgé
de 50 ans et plus et ou présentant des
comorbidités après lille et reviendra le
printemps et nous pourrons ensuite
rentré dans une troisième étape de la
vaccination en élargissant
progressivement le public bénéficiaire
de la vaccination à l'ensemble de la
population générale majeur avec une
progressivité ce sera les personnes
âgées de 50 ans et plus les
professionnels des secteurs essentiels
au fonctionnement du pays en période
épidémique dans le domaine de la
sécurité de l'éducation du secteur
alimentaire les personnes vulnérables et
précaires ainsi que les professionnels
qui les prennent en charge les personnes
vivant dans des tentes dans des
hébergements confiné où des lieux clos
puis tout le reste de la population
majeure je vous le disais compris dès
l'obtention de toutes les autorisations
de mise sur le marché cette première
vague de vaccination devrait avoir lieu
à la fin du mois devra durer entre six
et huit semaines une deuxième vague dans
la foulée sera organisée elle concernera
plus de 14 millions de français
notamment les personnes à risque
personnes qui sont pas dans des ehpad ou
dans des centres spécialisés mais bien à
domicile
le ministre de la santé a réitéré les
mêmes propos hier il est revenu sur
cette cette condition imposée par le
gouvernement aucune vaccination ne sera
fait son consentement des patients pour
aiguiller surtout pour épauler le
ministère de la santé dans cette
campagne de vaccination contre le coc
vide 19 le gouvernement a mis en place
un conseil d'orientation et de stratégie
vaccinale qui sera composée
essentiellement de spécialistes de
scientifiques et de médecins objectif
accompagner le ministère de la santé
dans toute cette période
olivier viron est revenu également sur
l'obligation la nécessité surtout
l'importance de continuer des tests
qu'ovide les dépistages on en est à peu
près 3 millions par
semaine un chiffre jugé insuffisant par
le gouvernement qui vient sur incite les
français à en faire davantage pour
essayer d'enrayer cette pandémie en
attendant la première session des
vaccins qui aura lieu comme je voulais
10 à partir de fin décembre
merci beaucoup ben hassen chébili pour
toutes ces précisions
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité à 14h à rester avec nous sur
rtl
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
comment on peut expliquer qu'elle un
groupe énorme comme areva qui est
spécialisé puisse acheter des mines
inexploitables ce n'est pas explicable
mais ça permet d'envoyer aussi des
gratifications on va dire des à des
politiciens nigérien la gestion
fantaisiste d'areva a des répercussions
incroyable jusqu'au président américain
obama donne son accord pour qu'areva
bénéficie d'un prêt de 2 milliards de
dollars alors que l'agent ce qui est
censé gérer ces prêts un avis négatif
je ne suis pas pour ou contre le
nucléaire je suis simplement pour une
industrie sans corruption parce que
cette industrie là si elle crée un
incident c'est pour l'éternité
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]